Hallo, hier ist Chaos Radio Express, Ausgabe Nummer 152. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und heute geht es wieder um, wie soll es denn das sein, ein Thema. Und das Thema ist ein Betriebssystem, was noch nicht ganz so lange auf dem Markt ist, aber für sich genommen schon eine ganze Menge Wirbel erzeugt hat und Staub aufgewirbelt hat. Kurz gesagt, es geht um Android, das mobile Telefon oder mobile Geräte-OS, was von Google auf den Markt geworfen ist. Und damit wir uns da auch halbwegs kompetent darüber unterhalten können, begrüße ich hier zwei Gäste, nämlich einerseits den Rodja Trappe. Hallo. Und zu meiner Rechten Dirk Jäckel. Hallo.
Hallo.
Dirk, du warst ja schon ein paar Mal hier, wir haben schon geschert, du bist jetzt auch ein Regular.
Ja, zum dritten Mal.
Genau, zum dritten Mal, zweimal hatten wir nämlich schon das Vergnügen. Einerseits Chaos Radio Express Nr. 90 zu Java, das ist ja auch eins deiner Anwendungsgebiete und das führt dich letztendlich auch hierher. Das andere war E-Mail, ich habe übrigens vor ein paar Tagen mal nachgeguckt, das war bis vor kurzem noch die längste Sendung überhaupt, die ich schon mal gemacht habe.
Mal sehen, ob wir das toppen können heute.
Ich befürchte nicht, ich hoffe nicht. Von daher muss ich zu dir gar nicht so viel sagen, aber Roger, vielleicht zu dir nochmal, du bist auch Entwickler, bist da fleißig tätig.
Genau, ich arbeite bei Art und Komm hier in Berlin am Wittenbergplatz und wir machen eigentlich mediale Installationen, also Multitouch-Tische, große mediale Installationen, Museen und dergleichen Showrooms und seit etwa einem Jahr haben wir jetzt ein Mobile-Team und ich leite dieses Mobile-Team. Wir machen hauptsächlich Android, weil das für diese Show-Sachen viel besser funktioniert als beim iPhone. Das ist halt einfach flexibler, mächtiger, gehen wir aber nachher wahrscheinlich drauf ein. Und naja, das ist so, irgendwie hat angefangen mit zu zweit und dann waren wir zwischenzeitlich bis zu sechs Leute, jetzt sind wir wieder auf drei runter. Je nachdem, wie man zielt, zählt irgendwie, sind es auch mal fünf, sechs nochmal wieder mit Praktikanten.
Das heißt, bei euch hat das sozusagen auch den Hobbybereich von Anfang an eigentlich gleich verlassen?
Genau. Also es hatte den Hobbybereich schon nicht, als wir begonnen haben. Genau. Also wir sind wirklich gleich eingestiegen in eine große Medieninstallation, wo wir solche Handys einsetzen.
Aber dann war das dann sozusagen auch erstmal was Neues?
Das war was Neues. Wir haben natürlich irgendwie von Java-Erfahrungen gehabt. Ich habe mir auch vorher schon öfter mal dieses Android angeguckt, wobei, als wir losgestartet sind, gab es schon das erste Handy auf dem Markt, genau, das G1.
Und du hast auch schon immer Java gemacht sozusagen, oder?
Ja, also an der Uni habe ich dann, also ich habe an der Uni natürlich wie alle anderen auch Java gelernt und habe aber vorher schon Java programmiert, habe dann selber Java-Kurse an der Uni gegeben und bin dann auch irgendwie in diese ganze Hiwi-Schiene und habe da halt viel, viel Kurse und Krams gemacht zu Java, dann mehr C++ gemacht, viel Grafik und so weiter, so auch zu Artcom gekommen und dann aber eben mit Android wieder zurück auf Java gewechselt und da war es natürlich ganz gut, dass wir auch ein paar Leute hatten, die lange, lange Jahre Erfahrung in Java hatten im Enterprise-Business.
Ja, wir wollen uns jetzt hier mal Android von verschiedenen Aspekten nähern. Was man erstmal vielleicht aufrollen sollte, ist so ein bisschen die kurze und belebte Geschichte von Android. Das ist ja nicht im eigentlichen Sinne eine Entwicklung von Google gewesen, wenn ich das richtig sehe.
Ja, also ich bin nicht ganz informiert, ich habe nur am Rande immer wieder was gehört und die wurde wohl gekauft, also Android, das Betriebssystem irgendwie gab eine Bude, die das entwickelt hat und Google hat das irgendwann aufgekauft und dann in-house weiter entwickelt und mich so viel darüber erzählt. Aber dann waren natürlich die Gerüchte groß, immer so vielleicht gibt es mal irgendwann ein Google Phone, keiner wusste aber so genau, was da passiert und ob die überhaupt was machen, weil Google kauft ja auch andere Sachen, einfach mal immer so zum Streuen, zum Verwirren. Und es hat ja dann recht lang gedauert, bis sie dann irgendwie...
Zum Verwirren meinst du, die kaufen das wirklich nur zum Verwirren?
Nee, zum Ausprobieren auch. Also ich meine, man weiß ja nicht, was in fünf Jahren irgendwie interessant sein könnte und alles selber zu entwickeln, obwohl die natürlich viel selber auch machen in ihren Google-Labs, was man in ein paar Jahren nur staunend betrachten kann, wie man das immer wieder sieht jetzt.
Na also ich habe irgendwann 2008 von Android gehört und fand es erst mal interessant, dass es mit Java sein sollte, aber irgendwie gab es ja keine Geräte und dann hat es mich nur so am Rande interessiert, immer so einen Blickwinkel gehabt, aber nie wirklich eingestiegen und dann kam im Dezember 2008, hat Google ja das ADP 1, also was dem G1 baugleich ist, vertrieben von ihrer Webseite aus und dann war ich, ich war gleich auch…
Also da redest du jetzt von einem Telefon?
Genau, also von einem richtigen Telefon. Ja, Android-Developer-Phone 1. Ach so, ok, alles klar. Und das konnte man halt auch in Europa bestellen und dann war ich ganz heiß und hab noch irgendwie auf dem Rückweg von der Devox, das ist so eine Java-Konferenz, nach Hause, hab ich versucht, am Flughafen mit meinem Laptop irgendwie dieses Telefon zu bestellen und war dann irgendwie abgeschreckt von den Shippinggebühren, das sind irgendwie 170 Dollar Shippingkosten und dann hab ich es erstmal gelassen und dann hab ich aber nochmal recherchiert und letztlich bei dem Dollar-Kurs, wie er damals war, kam ich dann auf 440 Euro und dann hab ich gesagt, so jetzt schlage ich zu und dann hatte ich auch gleich ein offenes Gerät und dann ging es jetzt los bei mir.
Was machst du mit offen?
Achso, genau, ich konnte selber RUT werden sofort, also man musste einfach nur ADB, ADB heißt das Programm.
Es ist interessant, dass es ein Linux-Handy ist, also da läuft ein richtiges Linux, also zwar kein schönes irgendwie, aber irgendwie ein Linux und dann kann man halt auch RUT werden und dann kann man alles machen auf dem System, also man kann...
Genau, bei den normal verkauften Geräten ist das nicht so.
Achso.
War das nicht sogar am Anfang so, dass im Hintergrund immer so eine Terminal-Applikation vor sich hin lief, die alle Keystrokes mit eingesammelt hat und wenn man dann einfach mal......
Reboot eingegeben hat, dann hat es Reboot, das Gerücht habe ich auch gehört, ja.
Ich habe es auch nicht ausprobiert, aber ich habe ein paar Leute von Leuten gehört, dass es ging. Also es war irgendwie ein Bug da, der irgendwie fehlerhaft irgendwie noch in eine Pipe geschrieben hat.
Okay, also halten wir fest, Android ist ein Linux-basiertes Betriebssystem, das heißt, der eigentliche Kernel, das ist ja auch im Embedded-Markt nichts ungewöhnliches, da ist ja Linux eigentlich ja mittlerweile, glaube ich, der ungeschlagene König. Allerdings ist es jetzt auch nicht ein Linux im Sinne von, so wie man halt einen Desktop-Linux kennt, wo dann eben auch das ganze User-Land dazu kommt und so, sondern ab einer bestimmten Stelle hört es halt einfach auf, sprich, man nimmt Linux, um die Hardware zu bendigen und Treiber und das ganze Timing, CPU, Management, you name it, das alles wird davon übernommen, aber ab einer bestimmten Ebene übernimmt dann eben Android und ja, ist ein mobiles Betriebssystem. Was macht das denn dann aus? Also, wie muss man sich denn Android vorstellen?
Es ist halt eine virtuelle Maschine und zwar eben keine Java-Virtual-Maschine, deshalb ist es auch nicht Java, was man da macht, sondern es ist nur source-code-kompatibel, wie es so schön heißt.
Was meinst du mit, dass es nicht Java ist? Also, es ist nicht die Dalviks Java von Sun.
Genau, es ist keine Java-Virtual-Maschine, sondern es ist eine Dalvik-Virtual-Maschine, die die David Executables ausführt, also DEX heißt das Format, das ist auch nicht das Class-File-Format von Java, aber der Source-Code und die API ist kompatibel, also man kann als Java-Programmierer gleich einsteigen, aber was zum Beispiel nicht geht, ist Groovy, weil Groovy zur Laufzeit Klassen generiert. Und es müsste dann zur Laufzeit DEX-Files generieren und das gibt es halt noch nicht.
Also ich finde es sehr interessant, dass die diesen Weg gegangen sind und sich all diese Mühe gegeben haben, einen eigenen Java-Virtual-Maschinen-Interpreter zu schreiben, weil im Prinzip ist es ja bei Java so, einmal compilen, hat man Binary-Code, virtuellen Byte-Code, den man überall auf allen Maschinen installieren kann und ab geht's. Und das ist bei Java eben nicht so, das sind diese Class-Sateien. Und das ist eben gerade bei Android eben nicht so, sondern du musst diese Class-Sateien dann noch dexen, so heißt das, also diesen virtuellen Byte-Code, Class-Code umwandeln in das Dex-Format und dann kann das erst als APK zusammengebundet werden mit den ganzen Ressourcen und installiert werden und auch ausgeführt werden.
Ist denn dieses Dalvik von Google selber entwickelt worden?
Das ist, glaube ich, aus dieser Firma hervorgegangen oder das ist so ein bisschen vor Google schon gewesen, glaube ich. Und jetzt zur IO haben sie jetzt einen JIT-Compiler angekündigt, weil bisher ist das irgendwie kein JIT.
Aber was ist denn jetzt der Grund, dass sie da eine eigene VM am Start haben und nicht einfach Java nehmen?
Ich hoffe, das kann Roger besser erklären.
Ich kann das mal versuchen. Also die haben im Prinzip diese ganzen, also die Java-Maschine, jetzt muss ich aufpassen, ich bin ja hier um mit, also 1000 Geeks hören zu, die wissen das alle besser.
Das Fall bei ist schon ganz nach oben gezogen.
Ich müsste jetzt nach googeln, um es genau zu wissen. Ich behaupte jetzt einfach mal, dass die Dalvik eine Registermaschine ist.
So habe ich das auch gehört.
Und diese Registermaschinen sind viel näher an dem, wie heute CPUs funktionieren.
Und sie haben da auch so Features eingebaut, dass Code geshared werden kann zwischen Prozessen und dass man aber vor allen Dingen, normalerweise in einer Java-Virtual-Maschine hat man nur einen Prozess, bzw. die Java-Virtual-Maschine ist der Prozess und da drin können dann verschiedene Klassenbibliotheken schon reingeladen werden. Aber in der Regel lässt man eine Sache in einer JVM laufen. Aber in Dalvik ist es so, dass in dieser einen VM alle Programme, die auf dem Telefon überhaupt in Android programmiert sind oder gegen die Android-API programmiert sind, dann auch in dieser einen Dalvik-VM laufen. Und dafür ist die auch optimiert. Und es sind aber trotzdem auf Linux-Ebene dann wieder verschiedene Prozesse mit verschiedenen Nutzerberechtigungen. Also einerseits gemeinsam, andererseits aber aus sicherheitsarchitektonischer Sicht wieder getrennt.
Das heißt, es gibt schon getrennten Speicher für die einzelnen Programme, so richtig auf Hardware-Ebene. Wenn einer daneben greift, wird er automatisch runtergeholt.
Aber halt auch gemeinsam.
Aber was ist dann noch die Gemeinsamkeit, wenn man nicht im gleichen Adressraum läuft?
Na, das ganze, die ganzen APs, also das alles, was zur Verfügung gestellt wird vom Betriebssystem, ist noch gemeinsam.
Ja, aber ist das nicht bei Java dann genauso? Also, das ist ja jetzt nicht so den entscheidenden Unterschied gerade.
Na, also eine der Sachen, die sie haben wollten, ist, dass das eine Dalvik VM alle, irgendwie widerspreche ich mir gerade selber. Ich muss auch gestehen, dass ich auf der Ebene gar nicht programmiere, sondern halt immer nur aus Anwendungsprogrammierersicht.
Aber wie dem ja auch sei, ist es halt irgendwie auf einer Mobilplattform extrem wichtig, dass man so wenig Speicher wie möglich verbraucht. Also, alles muss irgendwie nach Möglichkeit geschert werden und wiederverwendet werden und so weiter. Und schnell soll es sein. Und richtig schnell soll es sein. Und das hat mich halt sehr gewundert, weil irgendwie Android wurde jetzt released, gibt's schon echt lang jetzt und es ist immer noch kein Just-in-Time-Compiler da. Das fühlt sich also an wie SunJava 1.0. Das ist super langsam. Der Garbage-Collector ist auch ganz schrecklich. Also das ist fürchterlich, wenn man da eine Vorschleife macht und innen drin in dieser Vorschleife eine lokale Variable anlegt und das laufen lässt. Dann stoppt dich alle 100 Millisekunden, also der Garbage-Collector, für 100 Millisekunden. Der hält alle Threads, das ganze Betriebssystem, alles Rendering, alles an, räumt auf 100 Millisekunden und startet wieder. Kein Wunder, dass das so lang ist. Und das schockt ja fast, dass sie das gemacht haben.
Ich meine, gibt es einen guten Grund jetzt? Also mir ist noch nicht so ganz klar. Ich meine, es ist langsamer, es ist von der Architektur her vielleicht etwas anders, aber jetzt auch nicht so bahnbrechend, dass es jetzt für die Programme einen großen Unterschied machen würde.
Was …Ich glaube, die Überlegung war dabei, dass es on the long run irgendwie mehr Sinn macht. Also eine Registermaschine zu verwenden, anstatt eine Stackmaschine, weil da kann man irgendwie andere Optimierungen machen, besser machen. Eine Stackmaschine, wie die normalen JVMs halt funktionieren, sind zwar ganz gut irgendwie portabel von einer Maschine auf die nächste, aber sind nicht so nah an der Hardware. Und die wollten halt unbedingt was ganz Nahes an der Hardware haben.
Und …Wird das dann vielleicht seine Auswirkungen haben, wenn man auf Multicore-Prozessoren geht?
Kann sein, vor allen Dingen, glaube ich, dass diese ganze Android-Geschichte nicht für Telefone gebaut ist, wie wir sie jetzt haben, sondern eher so wie das Nexus oder ein Nexus in einem Jahr, also irgendwie mehrere Cores, richtig irgendwie Performance dahinter. Eine andere Sache, die nämlich dafür spricht, ist, dass diese ganze Grafik, alles, was man auf diesen Android-Handys sieht, ist in Software gerendert. Die machen Software-Blitting. Die benutzen nicht die GPU dafür. Die haben auch eine NDK und die können auch OpenGL und so weiter. Tun sie aber nicht für die Grafik. Das wird alles in Software root-force, wenn man so dieses G1 hat oder so, das ist ja ein 400 MHz-Prozessor oder so, und der muss die Software machen, also muss das ganze Rendering machen.
Bevor wir jetzt schon zu weit in die Details voranschreiten, wollte ich noch mal kurz so ein bisschen diesen Überblick abschließen. Also wir halten fest, es gibt den Linux-Körner, darüber gibt es eine VM, die sich im Wesentlichen als eine Instanz präsentiert, aber in der Lage ist, mit mehreren Prozessen zusammenzuarbeiten, sodass die eben auch sicherheitstechnisch ausreichend voneinander entkoppelt sind, wie man das ja eigentlich auch erwarten wollen würde. Also wäre das dann auch nicht der Fall, dann würden wir langsam wirklich die Fragezeichen kommen. Man programmiert in Java der Programmiersprache, aber man benutzt nicht Java die Umgebungswelt, wie man sie gewohnt ist, wenn man es gewohnt ist, oder wie man es bisher immer hat annehmen können, wo das Java so ist, dass dann auch der Rest Java ist.
Also die Bibliotheken kann man schon alle oder fast alle verwenden.
Aber die mussten sie auch portieren zu großen Teilen. Also die haben irgendwie dieses ganze Java-Zeug. Also die ganzen Libraries, alles, was bei Java normalerweise dabei ist, hat man auch zur Verfügung.
Genau, das JDK haben sie halt portiert.
Aber es ist sozusagen noch mal komplett neu geschrieben.
Ja, nicht komplett neu. Also es gibt ja auch irgendwie eine Open Source-Variante davon oder so. Also ich glaube, die haben... Ich habe mal irgendwie auf der letzten DroidCon jemanden kennengelernt, der meinte, dass sie da relativ viel gemacht hätten, irgendwie so bei der Portierung, weil es dann eben wieder mit, wenn es eine Registermaschine ist, wieder ein bisschen andere Optimierungen geben kann. Das heißt, die können dann anders Sortieralgorithmen implementieren und so weiter.
So, aber trotzdem habt ihr die Vermutung, dass es eigentlich nicht schneller ist, als man das jetzt aus der Java-Welt mit den Jits und den relativ weit... Es ist langsamer.
Weitaus langsamer. Auf dem Mobile World Congress wurde jetzt auch eine Turbo-Dalvik vorgestellt, die im Prinzip das vorwegnimmt, eine Just-In-Time-Compilation für den Dalvik-Code. Und das ist dreimal so schnell, sagen wir.
Wenn man es jetzt mal positiv versucht zu interpretieren, sie haben sich getraut, auch erst mal langsamer zu starten in der Erwartung, über kurz oder lang, mit der von ihnen gewählten Technologie am Ende besser dazustehen. Wenn sie davon nicht ausgehen, dann könnte man ja wirklich schon in Zweifel kommen. Das heißt, für mich als Anwendungsentwickler stellt sich das Ganze aber dann doch schon so weitgehend eigentlich wie ein Java-Environment dar. Ich habe so die Java-Basic-Frameworks, eben dieses JDK, so das Minimum. Irgendwo ist dann wahrscheinlich Schluss und irgendwo wird es dann auch Android-spezifisch. Das ist im Wesentlichen das GUI oder gibt es auch noch andere Sachen?
Vielleicht kurz zu der Entwicklung noch, das ist sogar so integriert, dass man einfach mit Eclipse programmiert. Es gibt ein Plugin, das lädt man rein und kann im Prinzip sofort loslegen. Macht ein neues Android-Projekt auf und dann kriegt man im Prinzip Geräte, die man per USB ansteckt, werden sofort erkannt. Da kann man drauf die Pleuden ausprobieren.
Ein Plugin, was von Google geliefert wird, was jetzt speziell für Android ist. Wofür sorgt dann dieses Plugin in der Eclipse-Umgebung? Also was muss es dann noch anders machen?
Das bindet diese Android-Debug-Bridge an, das ist so das Commando-Zion-Programm, mit dem man auch Programme über USB auf das Telefon schicken kann. Und da wird das halt integriert. Und der DDMS, der Dalvik-Debugger.
Genau, dann kann man im Prinzip noch debugging, also auf dem Gerät wirklich stepweise durchgehen und gucken, wo irgendwie Speicher verbraucht wird oder irgendwie was fehl läuft.
Und das Packaging wird halt auch noch integriert, dass du einen APK hinten rauskriegst und das zwischendurch Dex-Files erzeugt werden.
Das heißt, ich habe schon so eine Live-Verbindung zum Telefon. Ich kann wirklich meine Software auf dem Computer, auf dem Mobiltelefon laufen lassen und live debugging auf dem Computer. Gibt es auch einen Simulator, dass man das Ganze ohne Telefon machen kann?
Ein Emulator.
Das ist kein Simulator, wie man das vom iPhone kennt, sondern das ist ein richtiger Emulator. Das heißt, die starten dann QEMU mit Armprozessor-Emulation und der präsentiert sich dann auf dem Screen und fühlt sich an wie ein Telefon.
Das heißt, da läuft dann auch wirklich derselbe Code?
Richtig.
Beim iPhone kann man kurz einwerfen, dass es so ist, dass man im Prinzip, wenn man auf dem Intel Mac ist, dann wird es halt auch in Intel übersetzt und läuft eigentlich auch unter dem Mac OS X. Okay, das ist ja eigentlich ganz pfiffig. Was war jetzt dieses AA, was war das gerade? ADB und das andere war?
Was ist das? Das ist der Debugger. Der heißt... Ich weiß nicht, wofür die Absteckkürzung steht. Ich glaube, Dalvik Debug Machine.
Ich bin es jetzt nachgucken, aber das kann auch Microsoft.
Man braucht überhaupt gar keine Eclipse zu benutzen. Ich mache alles mit Maven und da gibt es jetzt auch ein sehr gutes Maven-Clacken. Maven ist so ein Build-Environment-Bild-Tool. Halt IDE unabhängig. Eclipse ist ein Integrated-Development-Environment. Ich kann keine Eclipse benutzen.
Also kurz gesagt, man hat eigentlich so ein bisschen auch die Freiball der Waffen und kann aber auch so die populären Sachen wie Eclipse verwenden, die dann auch noch mal explizit unterstützt werden und die eine gute Integration haben. Wobei man dann davon ausgehen kann, dass die meisten Leute eigentlich auf der Basis arbeiten. Also es ist schon sozusagen die empfohlene Art und Weise, wie man das macht.
Die meisten benutzen ja auch einfach für Java Eclipse. Also werden die meisten auch für Android Eclipse benutzen.
Ich persönlich kann ich ja mal kurz sagen, dass irgendwie Java nur erträglich ist, weil ich Eclipse benutze.
Und ich finde ja auch ohne Eclipse erträglich. So schlimm ist es nicht. Ich könnte auch mit Eclipse arbeiten. Ich will jetzt nicht Eclipse bashen.
Also du siehst schon Schwächen bei Java, aber du findest eine gute Entwicklungsumgebung.
Vor allem nimmt die mir diese ganze Tipparbeit und den Boilerplate-Code generieren ab. Das ist extrem notwendig bei so einer Sprache wie Java.
Das tut IntelliJ auch. Also ich nehme halt mal rufneunt IntelliJ. Und da gibt es auch eine freie Version inzwischen von IntelliJ. Aber wir schleifen ab.
Aber Hauptsache, was wichtig am Abschleifen ist, dass man auch mal wieder zurückkommt. Also Betriebssystem, Android versucht irgendwie alles ein bisschen anders zu machen als Java. Gibt sich aber dann immer noch sehr Java-mäßig. Sowohl was die Laufzeit betrifft als auch was so die typischen Entwicklungstools, die man zum Einsatz bringt, macht. Jetzt gibt es natürlich ganz offensichtliche Unterschiede im Bereich GUI. Aber wahrscheinlich nicht nur im GUI. Es gibt ja sicherlich auch noch andere Komponenten, die man jetzt nicht so unbedingt sieht, die bestimmte Dienste erfüllen, die man auch noch so benutzen muss. Also was sind denn so die wichtigsten Frameworks unter Android, die Android ausmachen?
Also der große Unterschied ist irgendwie, oder was sich ziemlich neu anfühlt, wenn man das erste Mal mit Android in Bewegung kommt, im Berührung kommt, ist, dass wir Aktivitäten programmieren. Also das ist so der Building-Block, mit dem man arbeitet. Man macht eine neue Klasse auf, die leitet sich von Aktivität ab, also von Activity. Und in dieser Activity, das kann man sich vorstellen als ein Ding, was man tut mit einem Stück Source-Code, der was processt gleichzeitig aber auch Grafik rendern kann. Das heißt, ich habe irgendwie eine XML-Datei, die meinen Layout beschreibt und kann dann sagen, okay, also hier will ich die Karte angezeigt haben und da soll der Punkt drin sein. Das ist so im Prinzip wie ein Screen. Also eine Aktivität ist den Screen, den ich gerade Fullscreen auf meinem Telefon sehe. Und von einer Aktivität zur nächsten kommt man, indem man ein Intent formuliert, normalerweise.
Gib mal ein Beispiel. Also was für eine Aktivität ist das? Nase bohren oder was?
Also wir haben bei Artcom nebenbei, neben unserem ganzen Projektgeschäft, quasi eine Applikation geschrieben, mit der man Daten übertragen kann. Das Programm heißt Hocker, mit Doppel C. Und man macht im Prinzip eine Geste im Raum, wählt also irgendein Bild aus und wirft das einfach in den Raum und jemand anderes, der in der Nähe steht, kann eine Fangenbewegung machen, richtig das Handy hochreißen. Und über den Server koppeln wir die beiden Geräte aneinander und die Sachen werden übertragen. So und wenn wir das uns jetzt vorstellen, irgendwie brauchen wir einen Screen und jemand muss ein Bild auswählen können. Ja, damit man irgendwie jetzt dieses Bild verschicken kann. Also haben wir erstmal eine Start-Applikation, wo man ein Bild auswählen kann. Also wo dann gesagt wird, ok, da ist ein Screen mit Grafik und da ist eine Option, ein neues Bild auswählen oder einen neuen Content auswählen. Und wenn man da draufklärt, also das ist schon eine Aktivität, die wir da sehen. Also wenn unsere Applikation startet, sehen wir diese Aktivität mit unserem Layout, unserem Screen-Design und so weiter und diesem Button Bild auswählen.
Was heißt wir sehen die Aktivität, die wird jetzt als solche angezeigt? Und ein Screen ist ein Bildschirm voll mit Zeug.
Genau, mit Bildern und aber auch Funktionalitäten dahinter. Das heißt da ist ein normaler Javacode, wo man sagen kann, irgendwie on click auf dieses Element möchte ich folgenden Code auswählen.
Oder ein Miniprogramm könnte man auch sagen.
Das heißt ich definiere, ich fange gar nicht an und sage, jetzt mache ich eine neue Applikation.
Sondern ich mache eine Aktivität.
Machst eine Aktivität und die drückt sich aus, indem ich dafür einen Bildschirm gefülle. Das heißt man fängt eigentlich gleich mit dem User-Interface an.
Und man springt dann halt von Activity zu der Activity. Und dann gibt es halt diesen Backbutton. Und dann kann man die Activities wieder zurückspringen. Und man kann jetzt aber auch von einer Activity in ein anderes Programm in eine Activity springen. Und wenn man dann den Backbutton drückt, kommt man wieder in das eigene Programm zurück. Also man kann sozusagen... Und wie man da springt, das sind halt die Intents. Also nochmal um auf das Beispiel zurückzukommen. Also man will ein Bild verschicken. Das heißt, man will ein Bild auswählen. Jetzt kann natürlich jeder seine eigene Bildauswahl-Applikation schreiben. Oder man nimmt die Gallery, die es schon gibt. Und man sagt sozusagen... In dem Intent sagt man, ich vermute mal, ich möchte ein Bild auswählen. Und dann wird die Applikation gestartet, die der User definiert hat für Bildauswählen. Das ist dann in der Regel die Gallery. Aber wenn es eine zweite Applikation gibt, die den gleichen Intent bearbeiten kann, dann hat der User die Wahl, wenn dieser Intent gefeuert wird, welche Applikation er nehmen will. Dann kriegt er so eine Liste von Applikationen und kann dann noch festlegen, die will ich die nächsten Male für immer nehmen, für diesen Intent. Das ist sozusagen auch die Mächtigkeit, finde ich, von Android.
Wer definiert jetzt, welche Werte es gibt für diesen Intent?
Das ist ziemlich schön gelöst eigentlich. Wir haben Applikationen, also Packages, in denen sind mehrere Aktivitäten drin. Für jedes Package gibt es einen Manifest-File, eine XML-Spezifikation, die man beim Installieren passendroid.de und weiß dann, in diesem Manifest sind definiert, welche Aktivitäten es gibt und auf welchen Intents die lauschen. Das heißt, du kannst meine Aktivität angeben, ich will aufgerufen werden, wenn jemand ein Bild auswählt. Oder ich will aufgerufen werden, wenn ein Telefonanruf reinkommt. Dann bin ich dran. Dann kann ich das handeln.
Oder wenn eine Webseite aufgerufen werden soll. Das ist ein klassisches Beispiel, wenn man mehrere Browser hat und irgendwie gibt es eine URL in der einen Activity, die ist geheiligetet und die kann man drücken. Dann wird gefragt, welchen der zehn Browser man benutzen will. Dann kann man festlegen, in Zukunft immer für dieses URL-Schema immer diesen Browser benutzen.
Diese Intents sind sehr allgemein formuliert. Gerade damit es mehrere Applikationen geben kann, die darauf lauschen können. Wenn man ein Bild auswählt, heißt der Intent dazu Pick. Auswählen. Dann gibt man einen Content-Typen mit an. Dann können sich alle Aktivitäten, die im Android-System verfügbar sind, sagen, ich bin dafür zuständig.
Also Content-Typen in dem Fall wäre Bild. Das heißt, wenn ich mich in dieses System hinein installiere, kann ich gleich mit deklarieren, und übrigens sollte irgendjemand folgenden Wunsch äußern, dann wäre ich bereit, diesen zu erfüllen. Es könnte um ein Foto auswählen gehen, und dann verwende ich halt den Intent, den alle verwenden, der sozusagen well-known ist. Der steht nicht schon in irgendeiner Registry, sondern das ist halt der, den man verwendet, und deswegen gebe ich den an. Aber ich kann mir jederzeit auch eigene ausdenken.
Genau.
Ich kann auch irgendwie sagen, jemand möchte gerne eine Idee haben, und wenn dieser Intent da ist, dann liefe ich eine Idee.
Wobei das ist natürlich dann gerade wieder schwierig. Also erstmal ist es gut, sich an die Standards zu halten, also alles, was es schon gibt, im Android-System vorgegeben oder so. Weil sonst muss man ja irgendwie einen Block eintragen oder irgendwie das publik machen, dass es diesen Intent gibt. Da hat Google noch keinen Mechanismus für. Aber nochmal kurz...
Also derzeit spricht es sich sozusagen rum.
Ja, genau. Wobei, also das meiste kann man mit den Standardsachen abfangen. Wir machen das zum Beispiel so in unserer Applikation. Wir können auch Webseiten sharen. Also Webseiten von A nach B werfen. Und dafür geht man einfach in seinen Webbrowser und klickt da auf Menü und sagt dann Share. Das heißt, es wird ein Share-Intent ausgelöst auf dieser URL. Und wir als Applikation, als Hocker-Applikation sagen, wir können diese URL entgegennehmen und wir können sie sharen.
Aber da gibt es auch noch andere, die das können.
Ja, da gibt es noch einen Twitter-Client oder was man halt installiert hat.
Genau, dann Google-Mail und irgendwie deinen eigenen Mail-Client noch.
Die kommen dann alle sozusagen in der Liste hoch und dann muss man das richtig auslesen.
Und dann sagt man ja sharen womit? Dann sagt man ja zum Beispiel Twitter oder Hocker. Und dann kommt die nächste Aktivität wieder. Die ist dann wieder von demjenigen geschrieben, von dem diese Applikation ist. Und die muss dann halt irgendwie diese URL entgegennehmen und damit dann das Richtige machen. Dem User halt präsentieren, was man denn dann tun kann und so weiter.
So, und jetzt sind wir ja sozusagen von den Aktivitäten zu den Intents gekommen. Aber die Aktivitäten sind das, was dann letzten Endes irgendwie was durchführt. Das heißt, in dem Moment, wo ich jetzt einen Intent äußere, bleiben wir mal bei diesem URL-Sharing-Beispiel, das ist ja sehr schön, dann kriege ich halt eine Liste von Programmen oder kriege ich eine Liste, ich meine, ein Programm kann ja auch mehrere Methoden anbieten, wie man das macht. Das heißt, das Programm taucht dann mehrere Male auf oder nur einmal.
Du kriegst dann eine Liste von Aktivitäten. Das heißt, eine Applikation, die du, also ein Paket, was in der Android-Market kommt.
Okay, das heißt, mein Programm kann sagen, ich biete dir an, diese URL zu posten, oder irgendwie zu shorten, oder in Papierkorb zu schmeißen, oder in Bundebilder zu überführen. Okay, gut, dann taucht jeder Intent als solcher auf, dann wähle ich den entsprechend aus. Und dann ist aber damit sozusagen eine Aktivität quasi gemeint. Und die wird dann hochgeladen, sprich dieser Screen, der damit verbunden ist, dieses User-Interface, das wird in dem Moment dann aktiviert und übernimmt auch den ganzen Bildschirm.
Genau, legt sich einfach oben drüber.
Okay, und der kriegt dann sozusagen die Daten übergeben im Rahmen dieser Intent-Verknüpfung, und dann kann er halt damit machen, was er auch immer will. Okay, verstehe. Und so programmiert man generell?
Ja, das würde ich jetzt noch mal ganz kurz. Also das ist das Programmierschema, mit dem man Grafik programmiert, an der Stelle. Und dann kann man natürlich wieder auf diese URL klicken, und dann vorher die Applikation, die man selber programmiert hat, wieder einen Intent ab, sagt Anzeigen. Vorher war es Share und irgendwie Receive und so weiter. Auf der Empfangsseite, wenn man ja nachher diese Webseite anguckt, dann sagt man einfach, bitte Anzeigen, View, und gibt die URL an, und dann sagen eben, wie gesagt, alle Webbrowser, ja, ich könnte die anzeigen, und der User kann sich wieder aussuchen, was er machen möchte. Und dabei baut sich ein Aktivitäts-Stack auf, also so ein History-Stack, wie bei Webseiten, also ich klicke irgendwo drauf, dann kriege ich die nächste Seite, und die nächste Seite, und die nächste Seite. Und dann kann ich den Zurück-Knopf drücken und komme eine Aktivität zurück, also da, wo ich vorher war. Und dadurch kann man so einen ganz schönen User-Flow zwischen Applikationen auch aufbauen, so was wie ein Attached-File und wieder zurück. Und, ne, will ich doch nicht diese Datei Attachen, sondern irgendwie noch mal auf meinen Twitter-Client zurück. Und dadurch hat man einen wirklich schönen Benutzerfluss zwischen Applikationen. Nicht wie beim iPhone, wo man so richtig...
Wo es nur irgendwie ein Programm gibt, und dann geht man in ein anderes über, und dann ist das andere weg und man kommt auch nicht wieder hin.
Genau.
Ja, was dann auch mal etwas verwirrend ist. Und funktioniert das auch gut?
Es funktioniert gut.
Es gibt Ausnahmen. Aber in der Regel funktioniert es gut.
Aber da gehen wir vielleicht ganz später drauf ein, weil dieses Modell hört sich jetzt sehr einfach an.
Worauf gehen wir später ein?
Würde ich sagen, auf die hohen Probleme des Aktivitätsdeckens und Multitasking.
Ich habe das nur aus user Sicht. Also wenn ich zum Beispiel in den Dolphin-Browser reinspringe und dann den Backbutton drücke, dann gehe ich in eine Seite zurück in den Browser und nicht wieder in die Aktivität zurück, aus der ich gekommen bin.
Das ist schade. Ja, aber das macht ja der Android-Browser ja teilweise auch, wobei die es ein bisschen schöner gemacht haben. Das ist nämlich so, dass du diesen Zurückknopf natürlich auch überschreiben kannst. Also das ist ein Hardware-Button, der ist zurückknopf, und den kann man in Onkeydown abfangen. Und kann sagen, na also den Zurückknopf, da will ich jetzt nicht irgendwie auf die Aktivität vorher zurückgehen, sondern da will ich jetzt eine Webseite zurückgehen. Und dann kommt es natürlich darauf an, manchmal will man das ja auch. In einem Webbrowser, wenn ich da so fünf Seiten hintereinander weggesurft habe, dann will ich das ja auch.
Ja, aber wenn ich reingesprungen bin, dann will ich wieder zurückspringen.
Deswegen muss das nämlich eine andere Aktivität sein, als die Standard-Webbrowser-Aktivität, die ich über den Home-Screen starte.
Dann würde das funktionieren, ja.
Das heißt ja, man hat eigentlich ein anderes Problem. Also was man vielleicht noch erwähnen sollte, das ist, also ist das, also sozusagen bei allen Android-Phones gibt es diese vier Standard-Buttons. Die sind immer da, wie das Telefon letztendlich ist.
Den Such-Button gibt es nicht immer.
Eigentlich sind es drei Buttons.
Drei, okay.
Suche ist optional, wobei... Das ist der Zurück-Button, der Home-Button, damit man direkt zum Home-Menü zurückkommt. Das ist so ähnlich wie beim iPhone. Und dann der Menü-Button.
Das sind die drei.
Genau.
Den Menü-Button... Der Menü-Button ist eigentlich, also manche Leute sagen, absolut überflüssig.
Ich finde den super.
Ich finde den auch super. Dann sind wir uns einig. Der bringt halt irgendwie den Vorteil. Also das ist ein Hardware-Button oder so ein Halbsoftware-Button. Auf dem Droid ist es zum Beispiel irgendwie nicht zum Reindrücken, sondern nur so touch-sensitiv. Aber er ist halt überall verfügbar und in jeder Applikation. Das heißt, man kann sich ein Screen-Estate sparen. Man muss nicht überall alle Menüs und Optionen und so weiter unterbringen, auf dem Screen, sondern du kannst optionale Sachen, sowas wie einen rechten Maustasten-Click, irgendwie auslagern, aus der UI raus.
Oder Settings. Ganz klassisches Beispiel.
Aber der Button ist natürlich auch immer da, wenn man ihn nicht braucht.
Aber er ist außerhalb des Screens.
Na ja, aber er ist ja da. Also man weiß ja nie, wann er wirklich seine Funktion hat.
Manchmal funktioniert er nicht.
Und wenn er das nicht hat.
Manchmal funktioniert er nicht. Das stimmt. Aber in der Regel funktioniert er. Das ist meine Erfahrung.
Auch wenn er nicht unbedingt das tut, was man von ihm erwartet.
Der macht ein Menü auf.
Ach so, ja, okay. Ich weiß, bei diesem Backbutton-Beispiel, wo er meint, es ist irgendwie mal...
Auch den Menü-Knopf kann man überschreiben, aber das ist wirklich böse. Das ist also, wenn man eine Applikation für den Markt schreibt.
Da sind wir aber mit einem interessanten Punkt mit der Konsistenz dieses Benutzerkonzeptes. Weil in dem Moment ist ja eigentlich ein sehr gewagter Schritt. Wenn man vom Betriebssystem her sagt, okay, alles klar, jedes unserer Geräte hat diese Tasten und ihr müsst da jetzt irgendwie mit klarkommen. Und ihr müsst euch ja auch immer irgendwas dazu einfallen. Weil da sehe ich natürlich verschiedene Probleme. Also erst mal dieses, es macht überhaupt gar keinen Sinn. Ja, also was weiß ich, ich habe ein Spiel und da gibt es kein Back. Oder gibt kein Menü oder was auch immer.
Na, das ist ja ein Boss-Taste.
Kannst du ja tausend Sachen Boss-Key. Back ist vielleicht in der Stelle jetzt nicht das beste Beispiel, weil irgendwie zurück, wenn man dann vielleicht doch holfiger. Aber man hat natürlich dann eben, wie bei dem Browser, schon so, dass dann eben die Programme sagen, ah super, da gibt es schon einen Back-Button. Back ist jetzt innerhalb meines Konzeptes, hat es eine bestimmte Funktion. Aber in dem Moment, wo dann eben der Button übergeordnet verwendet wird für dieses Aktivitäts-Chaining oder ich weiß nicht, wie man das so dann nennt, dann bricht das ja an der Stelle eigentlich konzeptionell, weil man ja auf der einen Seite sich im Programm bewegt, aber andererseits die Taste eigentlich den Anspruch hat, Programm übergreifend zu arbeiten.
Das ist wirklich so. Das Interessante ist halt die Philosophie dahinter, das halt so weit offen zu sagen und zu sagen, okay Programmierer, ihr alle, die Applikation programmiert, lest euch das durch, wie das funktioniert, und verwendet das richtig, macht das einfach richtig. Im Gegensatz zu Apple, die einfach sagen, nein, das erlauben wir einfach nicht. Das gibt es nicht. Es geht ja auf alle Ebenen rüber. Da gibt es ja keinen echten Zurückknopf, außer man legt den halt so fest, wie der in Apple oben als Menüleiste eingeblendet wird. Aber der kann auch mal unten sein, dieser Zurückknopf. Das heißt irgendwo, irgendwo. Und dadurch hat man natürlich auch wieder von Applikation zu Applikation unterschiedlich. Was ich zu Apple noch sagen will, die verbieten einfach irgendwelche Sachen, die noch nicht perfekt durchgedacht sind. Oder die lassen nicht viel Entscheidungsfreiheit dem Programmierer, sondern da muss alles genau so sein, wie es halt sein kann, damit auch der User immer das richtige Feeling hat. Die blocken ja auch aktive, also irgendwelche Applikationen aus dem Market raus bei sich, wenn die irgendwie sich komisch anfühlen oder irgendwie komischen Kram machen.
Ja, oder wenn die nicht spezifikationsgemäß. Da hatten wir glaube ich bei Neofonie auch mal was abgelehnt, weil es nicht funktioniert hat. Also es hat halt einfach nicht funktioniert und dann haben die im App Store gesagt, das funktioniert nicht, da müsste ja die URL geschert werden und die wird aber nicht geschert. Ich meine, das würde ich jetzt auch als Vorteil sehen eher, dass man davor bewahrt wird vor so einer peinlichen...
Bevor wir jetzt hier in die App Store-Diskussion geraten, vielleicht dann noch mal ein bisschen zusammenkehren, dieses Prinzip der Anwendungserstellung, dass man so mit Intents und Activities arbeitet. Du meintest, Dirk, da käme jetzt im Prinzip aber noch was Drittes dazu.
Genau, es gibt noch Services, die laufen im Hintergrund. Das sind sozusagen Demons aus dem Hintergrund.
Na ja, es ist kein Demon, sondern so ein Hintergrundprozess, der eine kurze Zeit laufen soll. Es ist nämlich relativ kompliziert, einen Demon mit einem Service zu machen. Der wird nämlich einfach abgeschossen zwischendurch.
Das Problem hatte ich auch.
Also es gibt die Möglichkeit, im Hintergrund Dienste anzubieten.
Zum Beispiel kann man auf einem Socket lauschen. Oder man kann darauf lauschen, dass die Batterie beschert wird. Das geht einfacher, da wird man dann gestartet. Also wenn ein Broadcast-Receiver, wie heißt das auch, Intent? Also man kann auch auf Broadcasts lauschen und zum Beispiel Battery Level Changed ist ein Broadcast. Das heißt, man registriert sich für ein Event, man registriert ein Broadcast-Receiver. Und wenn dann dieser Broadcast gefeuert wird, wird man gestartet, macht seinen Kram und ist wieder weg. Und man kann aber auch tatsächlich auf einem Socket lauschen, so zu sagen. Inwieweit war das mein Anwendungsfall. Bei einem XMPP-Client, also einem Java-Client, wollte ich halt immer mitkriegen, wenn was passiert. Und da ist es mir tatsächlich auch passiert, dass ich hin und wieder abgeschossen wurde. Man kann das reduzieren mit dem Beendetwerden und man kann auch, glaube ich, einen Alarm setzen, dass man dann irgendwie wieder gestartet wird.
Ja, das ist interessant, das hat sich in der 2.0er ab hier auch nochmal viel getan, also was die Services angeht. Aber prinzipiell ist es ja so, dass so ein Service, der ist halt dafür da, um im Hintergrund, während eine Aktivität da ist, Arbeit zu verrichten, dass wenn die Aktivität beendet wird, diese Arbeit trotzdem noch weitergeführt werden kann. Beispiel zum Beispiel einen RSS-Feed, da sagt man Update und denkst so, jetzt muss er alle RSS-Feeds irgendwie den ganzen Kram laden und so weiter, währenddessen will ich was anderes machen. Dann wird deine Aktivität eigentlich beendet. Das heißt, du gehst ja dann auf den Homescreen, der Code wird nicht mehr ausgeführt an der Stelle. Und dann kann der Service im Hintergrund aber alles weitermachen. Vor allen Dingen ist es halt auch interessant, wenn man sagt, ich möchte alle 30 Minuten einen aktualisierten Twitter-Client haben oder eben einen RSS-Feed, dann kann man sich auf dem Event registrieren, alle 30 Minuten möchte ich geweckt werden und eben ein bisschen Arbeit machen, sowas wie aktualisieren, runterladen, eventuell eine Notification posten, damit der User weiß, dass da jetzt was aktualisiert wurde und dann mich wieder schlafen legen und Batterie sparen.
Das heißt, diese Events, auf die man sich registrieren kann als Service, sind sowohl zeitbasiert, kann man dann beliebige Zeiträume nehmen oder gibt es da so ein paar voll definierte Zeiträume? Kann ich mich alle 20 Millisekunden wecken lassen?
Nee, 20 Millisekunden, also das habe ich noch nicht ausprobiert.
Ich habe es auch noch nicht ausprobiert, also man spezifiziert die Zeit selbst.
Aber sekundenmäßig kann man das zum Beispiel machen, also dass man so einen Tick kriegt, damit die Uhr abgedatet wird. Wenn man so eine Fullscreen-Uhr haben will, dann kriegt man irgendwie jede Sekunde einen Tick und dann wird ein Stück Code ausgeführt.
Man kann sich auch auf Orte registrieren, also du kannst auch sagen, ich möchte einen Alarm bekommen, wenn ich in der Nähe von einem bestimmten Ort auftauche.
Und muss dazu dann dieses Programmstudierende-Zeit laufen oder wird das dann in dem Moment auch erst gestartet?
Genau, es wird dann erst gestartet, weil es im Manifest beschrieben sein muss. Also im Manifest-File von deiner Applikation steht dann halt drin, Broadcast Receiver so und so, also ich will auf diesem Event lauschen und dann soll folgende Klasse geöffnet werden und ausgeführt werden. Also in einer Klasse eine Methode, es ist halt so ein Interface, was man implementieren muss.
Das heißt, man könnte sich so ein kleines Miniservice-Teil machen und in diesem Service, also Service definiert aber eigentlich nur, wie es sozusagen gestartet und, ach so, es hat kein User-Interface.
Genau, es ist ein Stück Code, da es ausgeführt wird im Hintergrund.
Aber ich könnte dafür sorgen, in diesem Code, dass User-Interface dann auch gestartet wird.
Genau, richtig.
Ich kann dann, was weiß ich, wieder ein Intent losfeuern und sagen... Zeige an. Dann zeige ich diesen Ort an oder was auch immer, dann kommt irgendwas hoch. Gut, das heißt, das kann auf Zeit basiert sein, kann also sagen, in einer Stunde bohren eine Nase oder bohren eine Nase, wenn du auf dem und dem Platz stehst, weil Geokoordinat und dann kann ich das irgendwie angeben, wie genau das sein darf. Wahrscheinlich.
Es gibt eine ganze Latte von solchen Sachen.
Sagen wir mal ein paar andere Sachen, dass man mal so ein Gefühl dafür bekommt.
Ja, hatten wir schon. SD-Card ready. Also wenn die SD-Card reinkommt, dann will ich irgendwas tun. Oder Power on. Oder Power down, das ist auch gut. Also wenn das Handy ausgeht, noch kurz vorher irgendwie ein paar...
Verhindern, dass es sich ausscheiße.
Strom nachlegen.
Da kommt der Intent irgendwie an, zu zeigen, you do not want to shut down, yo.
Was gibt's noch?
Na, wahrscheinlich auch SMS kommt rein und...
Ja. Das kann man alles abfangen. Und man kann natürlich auch wieder seine eigenen Broadcasts bauen, also seine eigenen Events. Zum Beispiel könnte man eine Applikation haben, die dem ganzen System mitteilt, dass eine Twitter-Nachricht reingekommen ist. Und dann wissen alle Applikationen irgendwie, dass da jetzt was passiert ist.
Sensor-Nachrichten kann man auch... Die kann man nur explizit auslesen.
Wir benutzen halt... da brauchst du einen Sender-Manager. Das ist irgendwie wieder so ein Stück API, was dann auf C++-Level runter demangelt wird. Also über JNI. Da gibt es übrigens auch sehr viele Sachen. Also, dass dann noch C++-Code unten drunter läuft. Das ist sozusagen die... Immer wenn es performance-kritisch wird, machen die das.
Tatsächlich. Aber das ist nicht für jedermann.
Also, es ist C++, was sie halt viel verwenden, um irgendwie so Media-Playback und so ein Kram zu machen. Man kann aber auch das Native Developer Kit verwenden.
Genau. Man kann auch selber in C++, mit eingeschränkten Libraries. Ich hab's noch nicht gemacht, muss ich gestehen.
Die STL ist nicht dabei. Und das ist doof.
Ja, und auch die C-Standard-Tippe ist dabei. Das heißt, man kann auch nicht komplett...
Also, gib mal ein Beispiel, wofür könnte man das jetzt verwenden?
Physik-Engine. Eine Physik-Engine. Du könntest dir eine kleine Physik... Also, ich hab das mal ein bisschen experimentiert ausprobiert, einfach eine Physik-Engine geschrieben. Auf dem... Also, in C, C++-Code und dann über JNI.
Also, ein Simulator eines physikalischen Modells.
Ja, eigentlich nur Punkte, also ein Federmassesystem mit Gravitation. So, dann kann man halt so Rigid- und Softbodies daraus knüpfen. Alles 2D war das nur. Und das wird alles in C++ ausgerechnet, weil da geht's viel schneller. Da ist nicht kein Garbage-Collector, der ein Nerv. Und dann wird nur über JNI gesagt, okay, hier, das sind deine Positionen, zeichne das mal.
JNI ist das?
Das Java-Native-Interface.
Interface.
Interface, genau. Und neu, also seit irgendwie Native-Developer-Kit.
Wieso denn jetzt? Ach so, JNI ist sozusagen...
Damit es ins User-Interface geht.
Damit ich auch von C auf Java zugreifen kann.
Und andersrum. Also aus Java.
Okay, also quasi die Brücke zwischen diesen beiden Welten.
Und seit Android-NDK 1.6 kann man auch OpenGL ausführen. Im C-Code. Das heißt, man könnte eine komplette Game-Rendering-Engine in C, C++, schreiben. Und über Java nur noch irgendwie derjenige dahin geklickt und das hat er jetzt da gemacht und er hat den Menü-Knopf gedrückt und dann alles...
Aber es wären dann sozusagen zwei separate Prozesse und ich muss im Prinzip die ganzen Ergebnisse davon über Interprozess-Kommunikation machen.
Ja, ne, das ist schon... Also es geht über JNI, es ist derselbe Prozess. Also ich kann da wirklich noch aufzugreifen.
Okay, verstehe. Das heißt, hm... Das heißt, dass eigentlich dieses System einerseits ein bisschen darauf ausgelegt ist, dass man es leicht programmieren kann, Anführungsstrichen. Man hat sich halt auf Java festgelegt, um sich eben auch viele Teerfallen sozusagen da nicht einzutreten.
Und eine große User-Basis. Genau, eine große Developer-Basis.
Developer-Basis. Viel Code, den man unter Umständen machen kann. Na gut, viel Code gibt es auch in C und C++. Nur die Wiederverwendbarkeit steht natürlich auf einem anderen Blatt. Man hat sich ein Modell ausgedacht, mit dem man relativ kleinteilige User-Interface-Aktionen machen kann, gepaart mit so einem automatischen Antwortsystem, dass die sich mehr oder weniger automatisch auswählen lassen, beziehungsweise man immer so einen generischen Auswahldialog präsentieren kann, wo der User das dann selber tut, beziehungsweise sich dann in diesem Moment auch festlegt für alle künftigen Verknüpfungen, so nach dem Motto, wenn hier eine URL kommt, dann will ich das immer nach Twitter, also leg dich da einfach mal fest. Wenn ich mich da festgelegt habe, kann ich mich dann auch wieder...
In den Applications kannst du es löschen, ja. Du musst allerdings zu der Applikation gehen, für die du es festgelegt hast.
Also könnte schon eine gewisse Suche sein. Da freu ich mich nämlich jetzt auch, wie man jetzt ein bisschen den Überblick behält, weil es natürlich schön, wenn man alles schön in kleine Kästchen zusammenbauen kann, aber das kann ja auch schnell sehr unübersichtlich werden. Zusätzlich noch zur Zusammenfassung nochmal, die Services im Hintergrund, die kein User-Interface haben, die auch genauso auf Events reagieren können, also die auch sozusagen einen Intent bedienen?
Die können keine Intents bekommen, sondern ein Intent ist immer, um eine Aktivität zu schalten. Und ansonsten gibt es im Hintergrund diese Broadcasts.
Aber Activities können auch Events erzeugen, die von Services dann aufgegriffen werden.
Genau, so können dann auch die mit einer...
Also Intent und Event, das sind sozusagen zwei Arten von Events. Das eine ist ein, das und das soll im Jusso-Interface sich abspielen. Und das andere ist, auf irgendeiner Systemebene soll was weiter gereicht werden.
Genau.
Starte ich nicht einen Service auch mit einem Intent? Da schicke ich doch einen mit. Aber das ist jetzt Start-Service.
Das kriegt doch noch einen Intent, oder?
Ja, kann sein. Aber das sind nicht die Intents, über die wir vorher gesprochen haben. Also es gibt auch so... Man kann den Intent auch einfach als Paket begreifen, wo man noch was reinstecken kann, einfach.
Also man kann ihm beliebige Daten mitgeben.
Genau, man kann so Bundleable... Possible-Data kann man einfach mitschicken und dann kann man so auch kommunizieren. Aber die Intents, die wir vorhin meinten, sind halt so global definierte Intents. Also man kann auch einen Service mit einem Intent starten und dem noch was mitgeben. Aber es ist nicht so, dass du im User-Interface einen Intent, also du sagst URL aufrufen, dann wird nicht ein Service als Vorschlag kommen, sondern immer nur eine Activity. Aber Services können auch Intents empfangen, aber zeigen da nichts an. Also es gibt übrigens eine Ausnahme, sie können eigentlich auch anzeigen.
Aber wenn es dann mehrere gibt, die das dann sozusagen konsumieren können, dann nehmen die das auch alle gleichzeitig auf.
Der Service ist da nicht als Vorschlag dabei, da sind nur Activities dabei.
Da bin ich mir jetzt überhaupt nicht so ganz sicher.
Man festlegst du ja fest, welche Activity, welchen Intent empfangen soll und darauf reagieren soll oder können soll. Aber wenn du Start-Service aufrufst, gibst du auch einen Intents. Es ist dieselbe Datenstruktur, aber eine andere Bedeutung.
Genau, also es gibt schon zwei Sachen. Es gibt die Intents, wie ihr das vorher meintet, und es gibt das, was Services sozusagen anwirft. Dass es da eben auch eine klare Unterscheidung gibt. Zusätzlich gibt es noch diese System-Level-Events, die dann eben auch in solche Services einfließen können. Und kriegt man schnell eine Übersicht, welche Services auf diesem Computer auf irgendetwas reagieren. Das ist ja dieser alte Vorwurf, oder immer noch aktueller Vorwurf, der iPhone-Plattform, dass solche Hintergrundprozesse in der Form so noch gar nicht möglich sind. Die Argumentation von Apple ist ja, das frisst ja auch irgendwie alles CPU. Wie ist denn da die Realität in der Android?
Frisst CPU, natürlich.
Das kann man so sagen.
In welchem Maße? Ist das jetzt störend, oder überwiegt der Vorteil?
Ich würde es schon als Vorteil sehen, dass es die Option gibt, im Hintergrund Sachen laufen zu lassen und im Hintergrund gestartet zu werden. Und inzwischen gibt es jetzt auch in 2.0, glaube ich, eine Applikation, mit der man gucken kann, wer den Strom verbraucht. Und dann kann man ja als User entscheiden, okay, mein Akku ist nach 5 Stunden alle, dann gucke ich mal, wer das war. Und dann sieht man da ganz oben steht dann irgendwie...
Man kann sich Programme nach Stromverbrauch sortieren.
Und das ist natürlich nicht so einfach. Der Mechanismus dahinter, der ist mehr so mit dem Daumen.
Das stimmt auch nicht immer. Aber so Pi mal Daumen kann man gucken. Ich schätze nicht, dass sie nach Stromverbrauch gehen, sondern die gehen wahrscheinlich nach CPU, nach Sensorkalibrierung oder wie genau man den Sensor haben wollte und so weiter und so fort. Sie haben da sicher ein paar Maßnahmen.
Dadurch kann man schon was identifizieren. Und dann kann man sich als User ja trotzdem entscheiden, das ist es mir auch wert. Ich will diesen Hintergrundprozess, der mir nach 5 Stunden die Batterie leergezogen hat, weil ich will im Hintergrund immer irgendwie meine Sensordaten aufzeichnen.
Ich will halt per GPS-Aufzeichnung genau zum Beispiel.
Also das soll der User entscheiden. Das ist die Philosophie bei diesem Design dahinter. Und nicht einfach zu sagen, das gibt es nicht.
Das geht nicht.
Genau. Man kann sich auch zusätzlich gerade anzeigen lassen, die ausgeführten Dienste, also alle Hintergrundprozesse, die gerade laufen. Das ist auch manchmal ganz interessant, einfach zu gucken, naja, was hängt da jetzt gerade rum, ohne dass man es nach Stromverbrauch hat, sondern was ist gerade aktuell da. Das ist aber auch erst seit 2.0. Das heißt, irgendwie früher gab es das nicht.
Die Versionsnummern, die ihr die ganze Zeit in den Romp scheppert, sollten wir mal kurz in den Kontext bringen. Also das geht ja immer alles relativ fix bei Google. Die bringen irgendwie eine Software raus, und dann dreht man sich irgendwie um und legt sich nochmal schlafen, und dann ist man irgendwie schon bei Version 5. Mir geht es zum Beispiel mit diesem Chrome-Browser irgendwie so. Letztes Mal, als ich es mir erinnere, war das Ding irgendwie in Beta. Jetzt ist es Version 5. Das hat bei Netscape irgendwie 10 Jahre gedauert. Gut, das sagt ja wahrscheinlich auch wenig aus. Was sind denn so die wichtigen Versionsnummern, die man jetzt bei Android zur Kenntnis nehmen muss? Also aktuell, jetzt März 2010, wo wir hier sprechen, man muss ja auch ab und zu mal das Datum sagen, weil CRE wird ja auch noch in 500 Jahren gehört, ist? 2.1 ist sozusagen der heiße Scheiß. Läuft aber nur auf sehr wenigen Telefonen.
Auf einem, oder?
Genau, auf sehr wenigen bis einem.
Auf einem, also demnächst was werden.
Im Moment allerdings sind halt ganz viele in der Pipeline und werden angekündigt, die mit 2.1 ausgeliefert werden.
Aber zum Beispiel das Funktionär Ericsson, das X10 oder so, kommt mit 1.6 raus oder so. Dass sie sich das noch erlauben können. Also 1.1 war 2008 aktuell, Anfang 2008. Dann kam 1.5, das war ein richtig großer Wurf, sag ich mal, auf meinem ADP 1 war 1.5 echt ein großer Sprung. Das war Mitte 2008.
Also ein großer Sprung, was die tatsächliche technische Realität bedeutet. Nicht nur was die Versionszahl betrifft.
Auch was die Apis vor allen Dingen angeht. Da gab es ganz viele neue Apis.
Und 1.6 kam dann ein bisschen später hinterher. Für mich war das erstaunlich toll. Als ich von 1.5 auf 1.6 gewechselt bin, auf meinem Android-Developer-Phone.
Da kamen diese Widgets auf dem Homescreen.
Das hat mich nicht so begeistert. Mich hat begeistert, dass es einfach schneller läuft. Dass es irgendwie die Prozesse besser managt und so weiter. Es war irgendwie ein bisschen angenehmer einfach. Das hat die Erträglichkeit gesteigert.
1.6 war aktuell bis 2.0. Und 2.0 kam im September, Oktober mit dem Mindstone, mit dem Droid. Also auf dem Markt. Mildstone und Droid ist dasselbe, nur andere Funktas.
Im September 2009. Droid heißt es nur bei Verizon. Das ist ein Trademark, also ein Brandname von denen.
Ach so, die werden noch ein neues Droid rausbringen.
Das kann natürlich sein.
Genau, und das ist dann 2.0 rausgekommen. Alle haben dieses Droid und Mildstone gekauft, wie warme Semmel. Und dann kam ja erstaunlich kurz, irgendwie erst vor Weihnachten, das Gerücht auf das Google ja ein eigenes Telefon jetzt irgendwie an alle Mitarbeiter verschenkt und das rausgegeben. Und dann haben sie gleich Announcers, dass sie es am 5. Januar verkaufen wollen. Und das ist wirklich ein extrem kurzer Zeitraum für, wenn die ersten Gerüchte auftauchen, bis zu...
Ja und vor allem, was sollen denn die Mitarbeiter da noch groß getestet haben in den drei Wochen? Ist ja quasi unmöglich, sie konnten doch den Auslieferungsstopp vom 5. Januar nicht mehr stoppen.
Also hier ist so nichts, das war dann auch auf dem Kongress unter der Nase gehalten worden. Von daher muss es schon eine gewisse Verbreitung gefunden haben. Was mich jetzt daran so ein bisschen verwundert, immer noch ist ja dieses, jetzt gibt es verschiedenste Betriebssystemversionen, die auf dem Markt sind. Und es ist ja auch nicht so, dass die alle gleich sind. Weil die Telefone unterscheiden sich ja in vielerlei Hinsicht. Die unterscheiden sich, ob sie eine Tastatur haben oder nicht. Und wo die Tastatur ist, unterscheiden sich in der Bildschirmgröße, Auflösung, Pixel-Format. Sie unterscheiden sich dann eben auch ganz konkret in der Betriebssystemversion, die ausgeliefert wird. Und wenn jetzt eine neue Version vorliegt, macht es derzeit so den Eindruck, dass die dann immer nur in neue Telefone reinkommt. Aber viele Telefone sind nicht mal in der Lage, Updates zu machen. Beim iPhone gibt es eine neue Version. Die poppt bei allen gleichzeitig auf dem Bildschirm auf. Und dann, ein paar Tage später, ist sie wahrscheinlich bei der Hälfte schon installiert. Warum ist das hier so? Was müssen denn die Hersteller selber noch hinzufügen, um aus diesem Android, was Google so frei vertreibt, auch ein lauffähiges Telefon zu machen?
Also, erstmal, diese ganze Problematik ist absolut zum Haare raufen. Also, dass man halt mehrere...
Zum Entwickler.
Zum Entwickler. Also, wir haben jetzt eine Applikation, dieses Hocker, das haben wir im Markt, das supporten wir runter bis zu Android 1.5. Und wir haben jetzt irgendwie 100.000 Downloads, knapp. Und, oh man, das ist wirklich irgendwie... Dann ändert sich auf einmal die Kontakt-API. Und wir können natürlich Kontakte speichern. Also müssen wir irgendwie zwei Varianten von Kontakt-Speichersystemen irgendwie pflegen. Und irgendwie, wenn wir auf dem Telefon sind, dann müssen wir das machen und auf dem Telefon das.
Aber über Reflection geht es ja immer hin.
Dann kriegt es raus, auf welchem Telefon man ist. Aber trotzdem, die API hat sich komplett geändert.
Was heißt das über Reflection?
Na, du kannst gucken, was für eine API habe ich denn jetzt hier gerade. Hat die die Funktion, die ich erwarte, hat die auch die Zettel, die ich erwarte, und dann nehme ich die Funktion. Und wenn es das nicht hat, dann muss es das andere haben, weil dann ist es eine andere Version vom Betriebssystem. Also man kann es richtig umständlich herausfinden.
Man muss es aber zur Laufzeit herausfinden. Man kann nicht ein Programm erzeugen, wo man so einen Bundle hat, wo alle Versionen einzeln drin sind.
Das könnte man auch machen. Im Manifest-File gibt man für seine Applikation, wo alle Aktivitätenservices drin gesammelt sind, auch eine Version an, ab der das läuft. Und dann auch eine Max-Version und eine Recommended-Version. Also so ein Bereich von Versionen, den man supportet. Und den kann man natürlich beliebig klein machen. Man könnte jetzt zwei verschiedene Varianten machen. Die eine ist nur für die eine und die andere ist für die andere.
Aber dann ein bisschen mit drei Icons im Appstore und dann verteilen sich auch deine Download-Zahlen natürlich.
Es ist nicht so ganz schön.
Also es wäre schon schöner, nur eine App im Store zu haben.
Wobei das Problem ist, wenn man mehrere Versionen pflegen muss, dann musst du sie halt pflegen. Du musst halt irgendwie aufpassen, dass wenn du jetzt deine Server-AP änderst, dass dann auch diese alte 1.5. Version mit gepflegt wird. Aber nochmal zurück zu meiner Frage.
Das Android ist ja Open Source. Oder zumindest wird das behauptet. Ist das auch de facto so?
Es ist Open Source. Man kommt an den Source-Code ran.
Vollständig.
Na, das Betriebssystem und die meisten Applikationen, aber nicht alle Applikationen, die du auf dem Telefon findest. Also Google Maps zum Beispiel ist glaube ich nicht Open Source. Man sollte es nur dazu sagen. Das Betriebssystem ist Open Source. Aber es muss klar sein, dass nicht alles, was auf dem Telefon kommt, Open Source ist.
Wenn ich auf den Google-Code wahrscheinlich gehe, wo Android liegt und mir das irgendwie runterhole und dann habe ich irgendwie so eine, ja, Plattform meiner eigenen Wahl, dann müsste ich in der Lage sein, das so zu übersetzen und anzupassen, dass ich das auf dieser Hardware zum Laufen bekomme. Aber ich habe dann nur eine Auswahl von den üblichen Programmen, die man so hat, also was weiß ich, Adressbuch oder sowas, wahrscheinlich dabei. Aber eben jetzt keine spezifischen Google-Anwendungen.
Ja, aber es gibt noch eine Ausnahme. Also bei dem ADP-1 habe ich das ja gemacht. Bei dem Developer-Phone 1 habe ich mir meinen eigenen Kernel und mein eigenes Betriebssystem gebaut. Und da gibt es noch so 3-4 kleine Libraries von HTC, die man schon nur als Binary kriegt und die halt hardware-spezifisch sind.
Und da kommen natürlich dann die Carrier ins Spiel und die Hardware-Hersteller.
Genau, das wird bei den Milestone sicher auch so sein, dass ich nicht, wenn ich eine Milestone habe...
Weißt du, was die machen, diese HTC-Libraries?
Das waren für bestimmte Hardware-Werder, die waren hardware-spezifisch.
Ich glaube, für Sensor und Treiber.
Treiber, ja. Und die gab es bei HTC, und HTC ist ja sowieso sehr weit vorne, was das angeht. Also da gab es immer die, nicht immer, aber inzwischen gibt es da die neuesten Images, die es halt irgendwie gibt, und man kann die da runterladen und dann auch flashen, wie man das möchte. Bei den anderen Telefonen, kommen wir da jetzt schon zu? Mit Root werden und so weiter? Und Problemen und Carrierungen.
Ich habe jetzt gehört, dass ja bestimmte Android-Telefone, ich habe jetzt beileibe nicht alle in der Hand gehabt, auch noch teilweise mit eigenen User Interface-Sperenzen daherkommen, also da sozusagen auch noch was hinzufügen, was bei anderen so nicht der Fall ist.
Hardware-Hersteller machen das natürlich gerne. Sie haben jetzt ein Open-Source-Betriebssystem, das alle möglichen Sachen kann, wo man auch den Android-Markt aufrufen kann und Applikationen installieren kann. HTC hat das gemacht, direkt vorneweg diese Sense-Oberfläche oben drauf gesetzt. Einfach die schöner zu bedient ist, angenehmer ist.
Ist sie auch?
Ist sie auch. Ja, das ist ein bisschen Geschmackssache, aber ich glaube schon.
Bei welchem Telefon ist das jetzt zum Beispiel der Fall?
Beim HTC Hero vor allen Dingen im Moment, was auf dem Markt ist. Das hat aber noch eine Android 1.5-Version, also das allerälteste, was man irgendwie auf dem Telefon haben kann, weil die einfach nicht hinterher kommen, diese Sense-UI und alle Anpassungen, die sie an diese 1.5 gemacht haben, zu portieren auf diesen schnellen Google-Haut-Versionen-Rhythmus. Ja, die sind gut. Also HTC, die haben eine große Entwicklungsabteilung und die haben glaube ich irgendwie, also sie waren extrem gut dabei, dieses 1.5 mit Sense auf den Markt zu schmeißen. Das Hero war usability-mäßig enorm viel besser als die anderen Geräte. Und da konnten sie sich einen guten Markt, glaube ich, sichern. Haben aber den Fehler gemacht, dass sie viel zu viel, nicht am Kernel selbst, aber an diesen Grund-Funktionalitäten von Android auch rumgetrickst haben. Zum Beispiel haben die schon Outlook-Synchronisierung eingebaut. Und dann kam eine neue Version raus. Und da mussten sie halt ihr Sense-UI portieren. Und dann war es zu anstrengend, halt alles reinzupacken, was sie irgendwie da an Modifizierungen gemacht haben. Und deswegen sind sie nicht schnell genug fertig geworden, bis die nächste Version wieder draußen war. Die hatte dann aber Outlook-Synchronisierung schon intern drin. Und zwar anders war die ARP als die HTC-Leute, die sich das vorher ausgedacht haben. Die sind zwar auch in diesem Konsortium drin, die Open Handset Alliance. Das ist ja im Prinzip der gegründete Verein von Google, von allen Carrierern und Herstellern und so weiter. Aber die sind einfach vorne weggegangen. Die wollten halt schneller am Markt sein. Das kostet die natürlich jetzt Schmerzen. Aber ich glaube, daraus haben die gelernt. Wenn sie jetzt 2.1 wollen, wollen sie auch mit einer Sense UI. Da zirkulieren auch schon die ersten Videos und so. Dann gibt es also Sense UI mit Android 2.1. Und ab da wird es, glaube ich, auch fluffier gehen.
Das ist die einzigen, die sich um ein eigenes User-Interface bemühen?
Xperia 10, also das ist von Sony, hat auch ein eigenes User-Interface. Und Motorola hat auch mit Blur ein eigenes Interface, wobei auf dem Droid ist das Blur nicht installiert.
Die haben ein eigenes Interface, das benutzen sie nicht.
Moto Blur, genau.
Das benutzen sie nicht fürs Droid.
Zum Glück. Aber für ein anderes Telefon, das Blur heißt oder wie?
Das Backflip wird es haben oder hat es schon. Und es gibt noch ein paar andere, die das irgendwie verloren haben.
Motorola hat verschiedene andere Telefone. Interessant, dass man schon so früh den Blick verliert.
Die haben ihre Sense UI, damit vertreiben sie ihre HTC-Geräte. Das Nexus One ist auch von HTC gefertigt. Da ist aber ein Standard-Plane Google-Android drauf.
Da hat dann Google das sagen, was da drauf kommt. Sonst steht da nicht Google drauf.
Auch bei dem G1 war auch Google drauf. Und es war trotzdem von HTC gefertigt.
Der Unterschied bei dem G1 war, mit Google, und das andere Nexus ist sozusagen Google.
Das impliziert ja mit Google.
Was immer das heißt.
Das gibt es ja mit Google.
Das ist wie das richtige Internet. Das gibt es mit Google und auch als reines Google-Internet.
Jetzt gerade war ja eine große Schlagzeile. Das Backflip kommt halt ohne Google, sondern mit Yahoo stattdessen, wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe. Weil es in der Suche. Genau, in der Suche und auch noch so ein paar andere Applikationen, wo Google sonst drin ist. Und jetzt spekulieren erstens alle, warum AT&T das gemacht hat, weil es kommt ja bei AT&T, oder? Und zweitens spekulieren alle, was Google jetzt macht, um dagegen was zu unternehmen.
Die lehnen sich zurück und warten nur kurz, wie das crasht.
Als Google würde ich auch gar nichts machen.
Ich kann dir sagen, warum sie das gemacht haben, weil sie mehr Geld bekommen haben von Yahoo.
Weil Yahoo jetzt mit Microsoft den Deal hat.
Alternativ gibt es ja auch das Gerücht, dass AT&T sich irgendwie Netz stellen muss mit Apple.
Dass sie deshalb Google nachstreben.
Und deswegen Google ein bisschen außen. Also ja, wir sind nicht ganz nur googelig.
Aber ich kann da auch nur spekulieren. Ich denke auch, dass es überhaupt keine Auswirkungen haben wird. Solange, aber ein Aspekt ist schon noch interessant. Was wäre, wenn zum Beispiel die Market-Applikation fehlt und du sie auch nicht installieren kannst? Dürfte das dann noch Android heißen?
Ja, natürlich. Ja, Acos macht das mit den Tablets.
Weil das ist ja dann wirklich zugenagelt.
Nee, die haben einen eigenen Market und die haben eigene Applikationen.
Gut, lass uns nicht zu sehr in vergänglichen Diskussionen, die unter Umständen zur Ausstrahlung dieses Podcasts alle schon wieder komplett überholt sind, verfangen. Ist natürlich eine interessante Diskussion. Weil was ja dahinter steckt, ist ja eigentlich dieses Was will Google eigentlich? Ich weiß persönlich, ob wir jetzt schon so wirklich an den Punkt gekommen sind, wo wir da hin sollen, aber wir machen es jetzt, glaube ich, einfach mal. Das Ding ist Open Source. Es steht unter welcher Lizenz eigentlich?
Ich habe nicht jetzt genau geguckt.
Ich habe mehrmals den Social-Promoter.
Also BSD-Lizenz spricht sehr frei. Es wird bis auf einige wenige Applikationen auch komplett ausgeliefert. Das heißt, jeder kann das irgendwie nehmen. Google nimmt dafür sozusagen kein Geld. Ich weiß nicht, wie es aussieht, wenn Sie solche Google-Geschichten haben, in welche Richtung da überhaupt Geld fließt, aber ich habe eher so den Eindruck, generell ist es eigentlich Google, was zahlt. Das wird sicherlich für diesen Bau dieses Google-Telefons ja, irgendein Investment sicherlich auch getätigt haben, ob es jetzt eigentlich eher HTC ist, die davon profitieren, oder Google, schwer zu sagen. Aber allein über diese Suche, das was du gerade angesprochen hast, ist es ja so, dass Google ohnehin, nicht nur im mobilen Bereich, sondern auch im Webbrowser, auch Mozilla Foundation lebt ja de facto von Google, einfach eine ganze Menge Geld reinkippt, weil ja ihre Intention eigentlich ist, dass alle Internet machen sollen. Und was denkt ihr denn, was die Aufgabe ist von Android? Also was ist sozusagen Sinn und Zweck, dass es existiert? Weil mit Android Geld verdienen scheint es ja nicht zu sagen.
Ja oder noch nicht. Ich glaube, Google muss sich nicht darum sorgen, jetzt zu wissen, wie da mit Geld verdient werden soll und kann trotzdem richtig viel investieren und das einfach mal in die Zukunft laufen lassen. Ich glaube, also ins Internet bringen ist wichtig. Das ist eigentlich das Argument für Google, Android auch zu machen, weil Internet wird immer mobiler. Es gibt extrem viele Dienste, also meistens ist man nicht vor einem PC, wenn man irgendwie was sucht und so weiter. Und deswegen kann man das eigentlich ganz gut machen. Finanzieren tut sich Google ja im Moment durch Werbung. Das klappt auf dem Mobile-Phone ja irgendwie auch ganz gut.
Ich habe jetzt auch gerade vor ein paar Tagen die Aussage von Google, dass die so Desktop-Computer spielen in so drei Jahren, haben sie glaube ich sogar konkret gesagt, nicht so die Rolle. Also war jetzt kein Pressrelease. Ich glaube, das war nur irgendeine Äußerung von jemand. Ich habe es jetzt nur so am Rande mitbekommen. Aber ihre Feststellung war, na ja, so Japan, dass er mit diesen mobilen Telefonen und deren Nutzung schon immer sehr viel ausgeprägter war, aus kulturellen Gründen. Dass sich dort eben einfach abzeichnet, dass einfach der Großteil der Suchanfragen, Großteil der Internetrecherche im Prinzip auf mobilen Geräten stattfindet. Dass sie das eigentlich genauso sehen, dass der Desktop-Markt da verschwindet. Deswegen wollen sie sich da platzieren.
Ich habe nicht so das Gefühl, dass ich jetzt viel Werbung sehe von Google auf meinem Telefon. Das ist eher denke ich so, dass sie als Marke präsent sein wollen auf dem Markt. Wenn ich mit meinem Telefon mit Google suche, dann suche ich auch hinterher auf einem Desktop. Oder wenn ich die ganzen Applikationen wie Google Reader, Google hast du nicht gesehen, benutze auf dem Mobiltelefon, dann benutze ich die halt auf dem Desktop. Und da kriege ich dann auch die Werbung präsentiert.
Also ich meine, mit Werbung verdienen die im Moment ihr Geld. Das wird auch vielleicht so bleiben. Aber wenn du auf dem Telefon googlest, kriegst du ja trotzdem die Recommendations und die Werbeinfos. Die haben jetzt auch dieses AdSense gekauft. Also irgendwie diese Plattform, die mobile Werbung macht und so weiter, wo man halt seine kostenlosen Applikationen mitfinanzieren kann. Ach so, AdMob.
Ich sehe Werbung in den Applikationen, das stimmt. Aber nicht, wenn ich Google benutze.
Das interessiert dir auch nur zweitrangig, glaube ich, wie viel Werbung du irgendwo zu sehen kriegst. Da verdienen sie ja im Moment genug Geld. Das ist ja jetzt nicht so, dass es noch extrem viel wachsen muss. Sondern sie brauchen halt Zukunftsmärkte. Und sie verdienen halt deswegen so viel Geld mit Werbung, weil sie genau wissen, wie du bist und wer du bist. Und das heißt, sie brauchen eigentlich die Daten.
Und was ich kaufen möchte, sie das wissen vorher.
Aber jetzt gehen wir nochmal zurück zu der Position des Entwicklers. Also wenn man sozusagen jetzt Android ist, Google versucht alles zu vergugeln im Sinne von, es soll ihren Ansprüchen an Nähe zum Internet entsprechen, die ja so Microsoft über lange Zeit nicht hart bereitstellen wollen oder können. Also so interpretiere ich das jetzt mal so aus Googles Sicht. Ich denke, ihr wisst, was ich meine. Und jetzt ist das aber auch eine Entwickler-Plattform. Wie fühlt man sich denn da? Die iPhone-Entwickler, die klagen immer so, dass sie irgendwie so zum Bütte von Apple werden, weil wir werden da irgendwie aufgenommen und rausgeschmissen, wie es passt. Jetzt darf ich meinen Porn hier irgendwie nicht mehr anbieten. So, das sind so die einen Klagen. Gut, ein paar Klagen haben wir jetzt auch schon gehört, was so die Zersplitterung betrifft mit Versionen, nicht wahr? Vielleicht auch die schwierige Entwicklung, wohin es eigentlich hingeht. Wie fühlt ihr euch denn da sozusagen als Entwickler generell in so einem Universum, was irgendwie den Eindruck macht, dass es eigentlich nur dafür gedacht ist, Google die Werbepräsenz im Internet für die nächsten zehn Jahre auf mobilen Geräten zu sichern?
Also ich habe von Google jetzt nicht so viel zu erwarten, was das angeht. Aber es gibt halt Foren, in denen man irgendwie Support kriegt. Und es ist auch so, dass durchaus mal Google-Mitarbeiter in diesen Foren auch mitschreiben und lesen. Aber eigentlich kriegt man von Google gar nicht so viel mit, wenn man entwickelt.
Ja, also wobei, ich finde die Grundhaltung sehr angenehm. Und deswegen hat sich auch atom.com dazu entschlossen, hauptsächlich Android zu machen, wenn wir irgendwie was für Showrooms und so weiter entwickeln müssen. Weil wir nicht so zu geblockt, zu betoniert, eingesperrt arbeiten müssen.
Genau, uneingeschränkt.
Ein Gestalter bei uns hat mal gesagt, wenn man für das iPhone programmiert, dann fühlt man sich wie in so einer Gummizelle mit zehn schönen Frauen. Das geht eine Zeit lang gut, ist auch ganz nett.
Und wie ist denn Android im Vergleich? Da sitzt man auf der Wiese, aber mit Nerds.
Vielleicht Woodstock. Keiner weiß, was es wird, aber gerade ist es.
Google hat jetzt diesen Android Developer Lab Tag gemacht. Was haben sie uns erzählt? Eigentlich nichts.
Sie haben uns Handys geschenkt.
Genau, sie haben uns nur ein Telefon geschenkt. Ich will das jetzt nicht kleinreden, aber sie haben uns ein Telefon geschenkt.
Was war das für ein Tag? Also eine Einladung von Google?
Ich dachte, als ich mich dafür angemeldet habe, dass sie da was über einen Android 2.1 erzählen, über die neuen APIs und über die Bluetooth-API ging das Gerücht zum Beispiel rum, dass wir darüber was erzählt kriegen. Und dann gab es halt so ein allgemeines Blablabla, was ich schon in der Firma vorher gehört hatte, schon zwei Jahre vorher. So viele Telefone gibt es und das ist der Markt und alles wird ganz toll.
Und hier sind die Telefone. Also es war eigentlich ein 4-Stunden-Ereignis, um Telefone an einen Entwickler abzugeben.
Also es war eine Marketing-Veranstaltung.
Also an der Stelle fühlt man sich als Entwickler wertgeschätzt. Also dort gibt dir jemand ein Telefon und sagt hier, du bist cool. Code mal coole apps. Und das finde ich auch, also tatsächlich ist es sehr angenehm, dieses so offene System zu haben, also wo ich auch in den Source Code reingucken kann. Also richtig bis tief runter und zu verstehen, warum das dann eigentlich so ist und was da so ist. Da ist nicht alles shiny und nicht alles schön, aber ich darf halt reingucken und ich werde halt dazu aufgerufen, innovativ tätig zu werden. Sachen zu machen, die vorher nicht gingen. Das System so offen darzulegen, wie es nur irgendwie geht.
Genau, das Nexus One ist ja auch wieder ein Developer Phone. Das heißt, da kann man irgendeinen Switch im ADB, irgendwie ADB OEM einschalten und dann hast du auch vollen Zugriff auf die Hardware. Das eigentliche Problem, weshalb man die Dinge routen will, ist, dass man den Bootloader auch unsignierte Images geben kann, weil sie die Geräte, die im Handel sind. Da kannst du immer nur ein signiertes Image mit flashen.
Also irgendwas, was von dem Carrier halt akzeptiert wurde. Die müssen das ja durchtesten.
Und Entwicklertelefone zeichnen sich halt dadurch aus, dass du dein eigenes Image machen kannst. Und da gibt es ja auch eine riesen Community, die irgendwie gemoddete Images macht. Also das ist echt ein ganz...
Das ist nochmal ganz langsam. Also ein Android-Telefon, was ich im Laden kaufe...
Ja, da kann ich nicht flashen, was ich will.
Da kann ich keine beliebige Firmware draufpacken. Also so ähnlich, wie das auch beim iPhone eigentlich ist. Das heißt, es ist durch digitale Signierung gesichert?
Genau, der Bootloader akzeptiert nur Images, die signiert sind.
Okay.
Standardmäßig.
Die mit etwas signiert sind, was der Bootloader akzeptiert.
Wo man halt nicht root werden darf.
Das heißt, man kann sich nicht einfach Android runterladen, selber irgendwie compilen für die Plattform und dann darauf installieren, weil man kriegt es nicht signiert.
Genau, es sei denn, man hat ein Entwickler-Phone, wie das ADP-1 oder das Nexus-1. Mit den beiden Telefonen geht es. Wobei, wenn Nexus-1 verliert, interessiert man sich interessiert.
Das Nexus-1 generell oder das Nexus-1, wenn man jetzt bei dieser Veranstaltung war?
Alle Nexus-1s, die kann man einfach bestellen. Ich war letztes Jahr auf der Google IO und da war dann auch die Frage, was halten Sie denn davon? Google IO ist die Developer-Konferenz von Google. Ein Google-Speaker hat gefragt, was Sie denn davon halten, dass Handys geroutet werden, also illegalerweise und so weiter. Und dann meinte der Typ nur vorne, sorry, wir würden uns wünschen, ihr habt alle Route-Zugriff, weil ihr seid die Leute, die dieses Handy gekauft haben, das sind die Carrier und wir wollen es eigentlich nicht. Und dann haben sie halt dieses G1, also hatten sie da ja schon auf dem Markt, was man routen kann, jetzt auch bei dem Nexus One. Es ist halt auch so, die sind einfach benutzbar.
Also with Google heißt sozusagen auch, du darfst inszenieren, was du willst.
Das Droid ist auch with Google oder so halb.
Oder das G1, was es von der Telekom gab, da hatte halt die Telekom den Finger drauf. Also with Google heißt nicht, dass man rout werden kann. Developerphone heißt, dass man rout werden kann.
Ich verwechsel manchmal G1 und Android-Developer Phone One, weil das baugleich ist.
Genau, die haben eine andere Gehäuseschale, aber ansonsten eine andere Farbe auch.
Und heißt das, dass sich jetzt um dieses Nexus One auch schon so eine eigene Firmware-Community entwickelt, dass man da sozusagen angepasste Versionen dann...
Das weiß ich nicht, aber für meinen ADP-1 gibt es auch schon Android 2.1, den habe ich mir letztens installiert, weil ich es ja quasi jetzt übrig habe. Und ich kann schon verstehen, dass es das nicht regulär geben wird, weil das einfach schweinelangsam ist. Und außerdem auch eine Swap-Partition anscheinend braucht, auf der SD-Karte oder so. Warum, warum, warum?
Was ist langsam?
Es ruckelt die ganze Zeit quasi.
Das 2.1 auf dem alten Telefon. Das heißt, die neue Version ist langsamer als die alte Version?
Ne, das heißt, die braucht mehr Hardware.
Die das G1 nicht......Hard Verwindung steht.
Also deshalb wird es wahrscheinlich 2.1 nie geben fürs G1.
Aber es gibt ja diese Entwickler, also so eine Community, die so Mods bauen und so weiter. Und da gibt es ja diesen Cyanogen oder so heißt der. Der hat lange für das HTC Magic irgendwelche Mods gebaut, irgendwie Wi-Fi-Tethering eingebaut und solche Sachen. Also den findet man relativ schnell, wenn man nach Mods sucht. Und HTC Magic, der hat sich jetzt einen Android Nexus One gekauft und macht nur noch dafür. Ja, aber vielleicht hat er auch eins geschenkt gekriegt. Wie auch immer. Jedenfalls entwickelt er jetzt nur dafür seine Mods. Und dann baut er irgendwie die HTC Sense-Oberfläche von dem 2.1-Image, was irgendwo mal zirkuliert ist, auf die Nexus Ones um und so weiter. Und baut da alle möglichen fancy Features ein, Stromverbrauch runter und alle Tricks, die man halt anwenden kann.
Und eine bessere Shell, dass man irgendwie Busyboxes hat und dass man Backups machen kann. Ach genau, es gibt einen Grund, weshalb man immer noch Root braucht, nämlich um ein gescheites Backup zu machen mit dem Telefon. Man kann sonst nicht alles backupen, weil man halt nicht rankommt. Die normalen Prozesse haben ja keinen Zugriff auf andere Prozesse Daten. Und es gibt auch keine Software, um alles zu synchronisieren. Also jedes Programm synchronisiert sich selber sozusagen.
Ach, man kann echt keinen Backup machen?
Nee, ohne Route keinen Backup. Ist ein echtes Missfeature.
Das ist ja auch so eine Eigenschaft dieser Telefon. Was ich wirklich auch als Vorteil sehe, ist, man kann ja dieses Telefon kaufen und dann für sich genommen standalone komplett in Betrieb nehmen, ohne dass man irgendeinen Host-Computer braucht. Das iPhone-Modell, dass das Ganze quasi mit der Software iTunes daherkommt, die sich dann aber auch wiederum um so Sachen wie Backup dann auch ganz nebenbei automatisch kümmert. Das ist ja hier so nicht der Fall. Und es gibt dann halt noch dieses Angebot, seine Kontaktdaten eben auch gleich von Google-Services zu übernehmen. Kann man da auch andere benutzen eigentlich? Also wie ist das so serienmäßig eigentlich gebaut? Wo speichert man seine Daten mit Android?
Also früher musste man, um das Handy zu aktivieren, sein Google-Passwort angeben und seinen Google-User-Namen. Das kann man mittlerweile skippen. Also man kann sagen, nein, Google will ich nicht. Es ist aber sehr angenehm, wenn man das nämlich einmal gemacht hat, dann hat man ja alle seine Kontaktdaten synchronisiert. Es ist so bequem. Also die umgaren dich quasi und umarmen dich wie so eine fette Datenkrake, wie es eben ist. Aber eine mit Flausch, weil es wirklich irgendwie alles sehr viel einfacher macht. Aber man kann das auch skippen und kann dann sagen, na ich habe hier irgendwie einen anderen, also ich speichere meine Kontakte einfach so.
Ich habe mein eigenes Google.
Ich habe das zum Beispiel so gemacht, genau die Kontakte synchronisiere ich nicht, sondern ich habe auf meinem Mac das Addressbook als V-Karte exportiert und das habe ich auf die SD-Karte kopiert im Telefon und dann habe ich es komplett importiert.
Aber gibt es denn kein Synchronisationsprotokoll, was eine Serverseite auch implementieren kann? Oder ist das wirklich nur Google Exchange?
Kannst halt Google Outlook Exchange machen, seit 2.0.
Also both kinds of music.
Aber man kann natürlich auch seinen eigenen Kram da schreiben. Man könnte seinen eigenen Synchronisierungssoftware schreiben, die mit seinem eigenen Zeug funktioniert. Weil das System ist wirklich so offen, dass man wie auch den Web-Browser oder alles Mögliche austauschen kann.
Auch das Adressbuch. Man muss das Adressbuch nicht mehr austauschen, sondern man kann den Adressbuch-Provider sogar weiter verwenden. Man müsste nur noch die Synchronisierungs-Schnittstelle. Und deshalb wundert es mich auch, dass es das noch nicht gibt. Weil eigentlich muss man wenig tun. Man muss wirklich nur die Synchronisierung implementieren. Und dann kann man auf den Provider der Daten zugreifen im Telefon und die da rausnehmen und reinschreiben.
Das ist eine Scheißarbeit. Also wir machen ja mit Hocker, werfen wir auch Kontaktdaten hin und her. Und bis die in diesen blöden Contact-Provider gelandet sind, das nervt richtig. Also, das würde man sich eigentlich bezahlen lassen. Wenn man so etwas programmiert.
Macht ihr aber nicht, die Anwendung ist frei.
Die ist kostenlos, genau.
Ach, jetzt hatte ich schon die nächste Frage parat. Jetzt sind wir schon wieder entgangen. Ah ja, genau. Sehe ich das richtig, wo du gerade Outlook gesagt hast? Also Exchange-Protokoll ist sozusagen mit drin, womit man Kontakte machen kann, E-Mail und diesen ganzen Climp-In. Aber es gibt meines Wissens auch kein Android-Phone, was auch so diese geforderte Vollverschlüsselung mit anbietet, oder?
Es gibt nicht bei Exchange eine geforderte Vollverschlüsselung.
Ja, also nicht generell bei Exchange, sondern es ist so, dass du deinen Exchange-Server so einstellen kannst, dass die gefordert ist, und das wird im Big Business in der Regel auch so getan, sodass du nämlich jederzeit über die Ferne sagen kannst, oh, Telefon geklaut, lösch alles. So, und lösch alles im Sinne von, dass einfach der Key, der Krypto-Key weggeschmissen wird und dann ist weg. Also das iPhone hat das halt im 3GS. Das 3G hat das in dem Sinne auch nicht, das qualifiziert jemand an der Stelle auch nicht. Beim Nexus war das auch nicht der Fall. Ich weiß bloß nicht, ob es irgendein anderes Telefon gibt, was das macht, das wüsste er aber jetzt auch nicht.
Ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass HTC schon mal in die Richtung weitergegangen ist. Das heißt, das nächste HTC-Gerät mit Sense-UI oder so, dass es sowas haben könnte, weil die das dann anders positionieren können nochmal. Die machen sowas, also die haben eine echt große Entwicklungsabteilung da, die viel Android-Programmierung machen und die gehen dann auch über die Grenzen hinaus.
Aber wohin wird das führen? Ich meine, es gibt ja nun, wer bestimmt sozusagen den Weg? Also liegt das mehr bei den Telefonprovidern? Oder ist das nur ein vorübergehendes Phänomen, solange es noch welche gibt? Oder wie seht ihr das? Oder ist es dann Google? Oder ist es diese Handset-Alliance? Macht da noch irgendjemand anderes, was interessant ist?
Also mein Eindruck ist, dass Google das schon zu großen Teilen steuert. Und zwar nicht, wie man das normalerweise steuern würde. Also durch Hierarchie und Aufdrücken oder so. Sondern die sind in einer Open-Handset-Alliance. Wahrscheinlich planen die da auch irgendwelche Features.
Aber die haben auch schon einen Wissensvorsprung. Die haben das Repository und die sinken auch nicht immer die aktuellen... Also für mich war es immer schwierig, die Version, die ich auf meinem Telefon habe, auch genau die Version runterladen zu können, wenn sie noch neu war.
Und das ist halt den Vorteil, den sie ausspielen. Also die machen so ein indirektes Machtspiel. Sie kloppen einfach eine neue Version raus, die ein bisschen anders ist oder irgendwie neue coole Features hat. Und damit sind alle Carrier und alle Hersteller und so weiter wieder angewiesen darauf, das halt wieder da reinzukriegen. Und ich glaube, weil Google so schnell voranschreitet und so weiter, können, selbst wenn jemand einen kompletten Fork machen würde davon, von diesem ganzen Betriebssystem, würden die spätestens nach einem Jahr nicht es schaffen, also wie man das jetzt bei HTC halt sieht. Die sind irgendwie immer noch auf 1.5. Diese Geräte sind halt irgendwie so ein bisschen so... Schade eigentlich.
Gut, aber so ein normaler User, weiß ich gar nicht, ob die das überhaupt interessiert, ob es jetzt 1.5 ist oder 1.6 oder 2.0. Ich meine, das klingt natürlich, 2.0 klingt natürlich viel höher als 1.5.
Ja, aber es hat auch andere Features. Also wenn ich jetzt jemanden mit Nexus One in die Hand drücke, also auch iPhone-Usern und so weiter, die sind schon... die sagen, boah, cool, der Screen ist ja richtig groß, das ist ja ziemlich fluffy, das fühlt sich echt gut an und so weiter. Und das war bei den anderen Handys vorher halt nicht. Das ist einfach nur eine Usability-Frage.
Dieser Marketplace, den habt ihr ja auch schon hier und da benannt, also quasi das Äquivalent oder entsprechende Gegenstück zu dem Upstore, der ja beim iPhone sehr erfolgreich ist. Wie läuft das? Wie kann man daran teilnehmen? Was muss man dafür machen? Nehmt ihr daran teil?
Ich hab noch nichts reingestellt, ich hatte sie mal kurz in meine Sicht. Ich hab mir damals nur einen Account gemacht, um an das Telefon ranzukommen. Da zahlt man einmal 25 Dollar und dann war's das. Und dann kriegt man noch irgendwie einen Key, aber das kann nicht.
Also es ist halt so, dass wir eben nur eine Applikation im Moment drin haben, es kann aber mehr werden in Zukunft. Man meldet sich mit einem Account an, muss 25 Dollar zahlen und dann hat man das Recht, die Applikation einzustellen. Um eine Applikation einzustellen, muss man die aber signieren. Also muss man nicht Google fragen und Google um Erlaubnis bitten, sondern man signiert die einmal selber, stellt diese Applikation dann in den Market und muss ab dann immer wieder mit derselben Signatur diese neue Versionssprünge signieren, damit Google das akzeptiert als neue Version für dieses selbe Programm. Und dann wird einfach im Market ein Upgrade getriggert. Das Schöne an diesem Market ist, man sagt Upload, File, also das APK, lädt man hoch und zehn Sekunden später ist es auf allen Telefonen verfügbar, überall. Da kann man direkt seine Twitter-Nachricht schreiben, hier neue Version. Alle sollen es kriegen. Ich glaube, das ist auch der einzige Vorteil von dem Market. Man hat irgendwie 300 Zeichen für die Beschreibung von deiner Applikation mit Versionshistorie.
Das ist schönes Doppelte von Twitter.
Aber Screenshots darfst du auch mit reintun.
Mittlerweile darf man zum Glück zwei Screenshots mit reintun. Man kann sich auch keine schönen Statistiken angucken. Das ist beim iPhone ja ähnlich. Wenn ich auf diese Webseite gehe, sehe ich nur meinen aktuellen Download, wie viele Leute das runtergeladen haben. Ich sehe interessanterweise auch, wie viele Leute davon das wieder gelöscht haben. Also wie viele aktive Installationen es gerade gibt. Das ist ganz spannend. Das war es aber auch schon. Dieses Interface bietet nicht viel. Man kann da nicht mal die Kommentare angucken für seine Applikation.
Gibt es welche?
Ja. Es gibt eine Kommentarfunktion, mit der kann jeder User sagen, ob er es gut findet oder nicht. Man kann Rating machen. Das ist die Grundidee bei diesem ganzen Android-Market. Dass Applikationen sofort reingestellt werden können. Da gibt es keinen sicheren Prozess, der guckt, ob eine Applikation sinnvoll ist oder nicht. Wenn sie nicht gut ist, ist es wie eine Webseite. Geht keiner drauf, finden alle doof. Um das zu vereinfachen und zu verschnellern, gibt es dieses Rating. Und Kommentare, User-Kommentare schreiben. Und das war es.
Was noch? Ist es beim App Store eigentlich auch so, dass die Bezahl-Applikationen alle verschiedene Währungen haben? Oder sind die alle in Dollar, alle in Euro? Weil in dem Market ist es halt so, du hast manchmal Pfundpreise, manchmal Dollarpreise, manchmal Europreise. Mehr habe ich noch nicht gesehen. Weil jeweils der, der es reintut, festlegt, was für eine Währung er sozusagen nimmt.
Aber der iPhone...
Da ist alles in Euro bei dir, oder?
Der ist ja eh nach Ländern geteilt.
Na das ist ja auch bei Market so.
Man stellt explizit für ein Land ein und danach richtet sich dann halt auch...
Das kann man auch machen. Das kann man bei Android Market auch machen, allerdings. Aber das ist ganz egal. Selbst wenn ich sage, das ist für den US-Markt diese Applikation, dann sehen die trotzdem, dass es Euro kostet, ein Euro oder zwei. Oder was auch immer man einstellt. Das heißt, das wird nicht umgerechnet in eine neue Währung. Das wären ja auch krumme Preise.
Gut, ich fand es ein bisschen verwirrend. Es ist auch ein bisschen verwirrend.
Man kann auch nicht unterschiedliche Preise machen. Ich kann nicht sagen, das kostet zwei Dollar und ein Euro.
Das stimmt, man könnte auch selber festlegen, was das kosten soll in welcher Währung. Das ist nicht vorgesehen. Viel schlimmer finde ich ja, dass man nicht richtig suchen kann. Ich meine, der Android-Markt ist eine Applikation von Google. Bei Google erwarte ich, dass ich da gescheit nach Applikationen suchen kann. Aber wenn ich nicht genau den richtigen Namen eingebe, dann finde ich es in der Regel nicht. Also das ist maximal noch ein Substream-Match. Das ist schon immer so gewesen. Das ist total unglaublich.
Das heißt, man muss in diesen 300 Zeichen textueller Beschreibung von seiner Applikation und Versionshistorie und was auch immer man da unterbringen möchte, auch noch eine Tech-Cloud, also Text mit angegeben, damit man gefunden wird überhaupt. Also wenn ich da irgendwie Hocker, Throw-Data reinschreibe, dann muss ich auch noch Transfer, Information, Contacts, Images und so. Das muss ich alles mit in diesen kleinen Beschreibungstexten mit eingeben.
Damit sieht ja manchmal so komisch aus.
Genau, sonst findet das halt keiner. Und ich kann auch nicht sagen, gib mir mal ähnliche Applikationen oder Leute, die diese Applikation installiert haben.
Ich finde auch, vor allen Dingen auch kein offizielles Web-Interface für den Market. Es gibt halt Circuit, da kann man immer sich in RSS-Feed, also C, Y, R, K, I, T, da kann man sich immer ein Feed von aktuellen Applikationen geben lassen und auch drin suchen. Ich glaube, da kann man sogar ein bisschen besser drin suchen. Und da kann man auch die Bewertungen einsehen. Aber von Google gibt es keine Market-Webseite. Hätte ich eigentlich erwartet, ist man gesagt.
Ist man denn festgelegt auf diesen Android-Market?
Der ist optional.
Also man kann einfach seinen APK-File auf einer Webseite zum Download anbieten, wenn es kostenlos sein soll. APK ist das Bundle-Format, mit dem man Applikationen...
Also in dem man Programme ausliefert.
Genau.
Das ist dann die SIP-Format, oder? Dann gibt es noch einen kleinen interessanten Punkt.
Moment, das habe ich jetzt nicht verstanden. Also man kann einfach das APK-File nehmen und einfach installieren. Man muss nicht über den Store gehen.
Genau. Man kann das runterladen auf die SD-Karte. Und wenn man einen Dateibrowser installiert hat, es gibt relativ viele File-Manager für Android. Und wenn man dann irgendwie auf seine SD-Karte geht und dann auf dieses APK-File klickt, dann kommt einfach direkt, möchten Sie es installieren? Ja. Und dann ist es drauf.
Oder man wird es auf einen internen Speicher...
Da wird es natürlich intern gespeichert, genau. Also auf der SD-Karte liegt dann nur das APK-File, damit man halt drankommt. Man kann es auch über die ADB-File...
Und auch direkt runterladen. Also du kannst auch im Browser direkt einen Link auf ein APK-File haben und dann wird es auch gleich installiert. Also man kommt ja schon bequem auch ohne Mark. Es gibt auch Konkurrenzmärkte, Slide-MI und noch zwei, drei andere.
Wie kann man einfach angeben, dass man nie jetzt verwenden möchte?
Da muss man eine App installieren und die ist dann der Market. Weil der Market auf dem Telefon ist ja auch nur eine Applikation. So wie der App Store auf dem iPhone auch nur eine Applikation ist.
So, wenn man da jetzt so betrieblich installieren kann, was tut Android so im Bereich Sicherheit? Also inwiefern gibt es da Einschränkungen, um sich vor böser Malware zu schützen?
Also jede normale Applikation läuft unter einem eigenen Usernamen. Also unter einem eigenen User und kann somit auch nur auf die eigenen Daten zugreifen und, wenn freigegeben, auf die SD-Karte. Also es gibt ein Permissionsystem.
Gibt es dann ein geteiltes Datalsystem oder hat jedes Programm sein eigenes?
Jedes Programm hat sein eigenes, internes sozusagen. Aber die SD-Karte ist, wenn man die Permission gegeben hat, für alle gemeinsam.
Also es gibt ein, das ist interessant, das ist im Gegensatz zum iPhone auch ein Herausstellungsmerkmal, finde ich, eben dieses rechte Management. Also in seinem Manifest-Datei, die im APK mit drin sein muss, muss man reinschreiben, auf welche Funktion das Programm zugreifen möchte. Also irgendwelche Aktivitäten, die da drin sind.
SMS verschicken, Internet machen, auf die SD-Karte zugreifen.
Man kann auch sonst auf diese Dinger zugreifen wollen, das heißt, den AP, die AP gibt es trotzdem. Man kriegt aber dann eine Permission Denied Exception. Das heißt, das fliegt einem voll um die Ohren. Wenn man diese Permission nicht hat. Und diese Permission wird einem angezeigt, bevor man das Programm installieren möchte. Dem User. Der User kann entscheiden, aha, das Ding will auf meine SD-Karte zugreifen und will ins Internet, finde ich nicht gut, installiere ich nicht.
Es gibt nur all or nothing.
Entweder du willst das Programm oder willst es nicht. Das ist ein bisschen auch...
Aber es ist immer noch besser, als es früher bei J2MI war, wo du für jedes CD in deinem Fallsystem den User fragen musstest, ob du jetzt auf dieses Verzeichnis zugreifen darfst und das nur verhindern konntest, wenn du signiert warst mit einer Signatur von einer Certifying Authority, die 300 Dollar im Jahr gekostet hat. Und dann reicht auch nicht eine, sondern du brauchst es für jeden Hersteller unter Umständen ein eigenes Root-Zertifikat, für jeden Carrier ein eigenes Root-Zertifikat und dann am besten noch für jedes Gerät ein eigenes Root-Zertifikat.
Aber wenn man jetzt mal so ein bisschen böser über Malware nachdenkt, und das wird so...
Es gab da schon eine.
Es gab schon eine?
Ja, eine Banken-Applikation für Android, die deine Bankdaten woandershin geschickt hat oder... Ich weiß nicht genau, was sie gemacht hat, aber so eine Bank-Applikation hat ja durchaus Zugriff auf sensitive Daten. Aber das lässt sich mit dem iPhone App Store auch nicht verhindern.
Klar, das ist ja jetzt Software, die, sagen wir mal, wenn ich sie benutze, was anderes tut, als sie behauptet, dass sie es tut. Aber wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe mit diesen ganzen Events und der Art und Weise, kann man sich dann, ich könnte mich ja im Prinzip auch für jeden, wie hieß es noch gleich, Intent registrieren und sozusagen mich eigentlich in jederlei Brückenflow mit einklinken.
Aber bei einem Intent, wenn er abgefeuert wird, dann wird ja erst eine Optionsliste präsentiert von was man auswählen möchte. Genau, außer man will diese Applikation und will das damit verschicken. Und wenn sie dann nicht tut, was sie verspricht, dann kann man sie ja wieder deinstallieren oder ein schlechtes Kommentar schreiben oder das Rating runterdrehen.
Was zum Beispiel auch noch vorstellbar wäre als Mail wäre etwas, was SMS an Kurzwahlen verschickt, die dann kostenpflichtige Abos auslösen.
Ja, das ist eigentlich so der Klassiker.
Aber da ist mir jetzt nichts bekannt, dass es das schon gibt. Ich meine, die Entwickler sind ja über die Sachen, die über den Market kommen, auch rückverfolgbar. Also ich zum Beispiel musste eine Kreditkarte angeben. Und wenn ich jetzt eine Mailware reinstelle, die SMS-Abos auslöst, dann könnte Google schon auf mich zukommen und sagen, hier, was soll denn das?
Also Google behält sich auch tatsächlich das Recht vor, so ähnlich wie Apple auch, eine Remote-Löschaktion von der App durchzuführen. Im Zweifelsfall. Das machen die halt sehr selten. Also das machen die nicht wirklich. Außer es ist halt wirklich sowas wie eine Banksoftware, die offensichtlich...
Nee, selbst da haben sie das, glaube ich, nicht gemacht. Also ich wüsste nicht, dass sie die zurückgezogen hätten. Oder ich wüsste auch nicht, dass sie es wirklich können. Also es gibt die Behauptung, dass sie es können. Und ich kann es mir auch vorstellen, dass sie es können. Aber ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob sie es wirklich können.
Vielleicht bei den With-Google-Phones. Es ist halt irgendwie schwierig mit diesem Market. Also diese ganze rechte Sache, das stört. Also bei Hocker zum Beispiel, wo wir halt Daten transferieren, müssen wir auf alles zugreifen. Also wir brauchen Internetzugriffe, wir brauchen deine Kontaktdaten, wir müssen auf deine Bookmarks zugreifen können. Außerdem wollen wir auf die SD-Karte, weil wir ja Dateien abspeichern und hochladen und so weiter. Weil wir uns so krass ins System integrieren wollen, wollen wir quasi, wir haben glaube ich 18 Permissions, die wir brauchen. Und das führt uns natürlich ad absurdum irgendwie diese ganze Permission-List oder so, weil ja, okay, ich will Daten übertragen. Und ich vertraue Artkommen, knickknack. Und das muss man halt akzeptieren als User.
Habt ihr da irgendwelche Erfahrungen, wie das von den Usern auch so akzeptiert wird? Ist es da nicht so, dass sie dann einfach generell sagen, entweder ja und arm, macht doch was ihr wollt, oder sagen, ihr tut da irgendwelche schlimmen Dinge, geht weg?
Also ich meine, wie Google, wenn auch wir irgendwie ordentlich benutzt, die Leute verwenden das einfach. Den meisten ist es wahrscheinlich egal oder vertrauen uns halt so weit, dass wir damit nichts Schlimmes anstellen. Es gab aber mal irgendwie so Fragen, warum wollt ihr eigentlich irgendwie auf meine SMS zugreifen? So, das kann ich mal erklären. Das steht natürlich auch in unserem Blog und so weiter, aber auch auf den FAQ-Seiten. Es ist halt so, dass wir versuchen bei Hocker, die Daten nicht selber zu speichern. Wir wollen die Daten nicht speichern. Wir wollen uns in das Android-System integrieren, damit man die Applikation, die man so kennt, verwendet. So, wir können Text-Messages verschicken. Dann kannst du eine Nachricht eingeben und die an jemanden rüber werfen. Und wo speichert man die App auf dem Android-System? Das einzige, den einzigen Content-Provider, den wir überhaupt haben an der Stelle, ist SMS. Das heißt, wir verschicken keine SMSs und wir lesen auch keine SMSs, sondern wir brauchen diese Permission, damit wir in diesen SMS-Storage reinschreiben können. Und das wird halt nicht ordentlich aufgeteilt. Das wird dann auch nicht wieder so aufgeschlüsselt, dass man sagen kann, ich will da nur was reinputten, ich will nicht wissen, was da drin ist, sondern ich will dann ein neues Datum hinzunehmen.
Du benutzt es einfach nur als Zwischenspeicher sozusagen.
Nenn dich ja als Endspeicher. Das heißt, später kann ich dann in meine SMS-Applikation gehen und sehe dann irgendwie einen Kontakt-Hocker, von dem dann diese ganzen Daten gekommen sind.
Ach so, also wäre es gekommen wie eine SMS, nur dass es von woanders kommt.
Genau, so ist es auch bei den Bildern. Wenn wir ein Bild fangen, dann speichern wir das in der Bildergalerie und öffnen dann auch die Bildergalerie. Und später, wenn ich in die Bildergalerie gehe, ist es so, als hätte ich das von woanders auch hergekriegt. Das ist halt irgendwie extrem integriert in die Umgebung.
Also aus Usersicht kann ich sagen, ich gucke mir die Permissions überflugsmäßig an, aber drücke dann doch immer Ja.
Alter, Ja-Sager.
Ich hätte es mir auch nicht installiert, wenn ich es nicht installieren wollte, letztlich. Aber es ist schon mal interessant zu sehen, was da so für Permissions verwendet werden. Letztlich ist es wie auf dem Mac oder auf dem PC. Man installiert die Software und wenn man von irgendjemandem hört, dass sie Scheiße baut, dann löscht man sie wieder und sagt es weiter. Wenn man es hört. Ich denke, das geht vermutlich nicht anders mit einem offenen System.
Jetzt haben wir natürlich viel Android mit dem iPhone verglichen. Habt ihr eigentlich irgendwelche Erfahrungen mit anderen mobilen OS'n vorher schon mal gesammelt? Oder war das jetzt im Prinzip auch so euer Einstieg in die Welt? Ich habe vorher Series 60 und UIQ, also Symbian mit speziellem User-Interface oben drauf gemacht.
Geputzt und ein bisschen programmiert. Ich habe mich immer vom Mobile ferngehalten, weil ich das so nervig fand, das zu programmieren. Wir haben an der Uni mal so ein Projekt gehabt, wo andere Studenten, da war ich halt nur irgendwie schon Hiwi und habe die ein bisschen mitbetreut, die haben ein Marker-Tracking-System auf Windows Mobile, damals irgendwie 6 oder 5 oder sowas programmiert. Das war so anstrengend für die, die haben sehr, sehr, sehr gelitten. Und wenn ich da mal in den Sourcecode geguckt habe, habe ich nicht nur gelitten, sondern auch gekotzt. Metaphorisch gesehen, und das fand ich halt immer so anstrengend, ich wollte das nicht. Ich fand Mobile immer spannend, aber irgendwie war es noch nicht reif dafür. Und mit Android, als ich gehört habe, endlich ein Linux-Handy, darauf warte ich seit sieben Jahren.
Das gab schon vorher eins.
Ja, aber das war mir zu fürchterlich. Ich wollte halt irgendwie ein System haben, was funktioniert und was irgendwie mit den Sachen, was man programmieren möchte, auch dann schnell zu einem Ergebnis kommt und nicht so rumfuddelt. Und das hat Android tatsächlich auch erfüllt, also dieses Versprechen. Einfach ein offenes System zu haben, wo man schnell zu extrem coolen Ergebnissen kommt und mit ein bisschen Nachdenken auch zu extrem innovativer anderen Workflows, wie man es halt irgendwie vorher noch nie verwendet hat.
Wenn man jetzt so als Entwickler Interesse hat, was für Android zu machen, was sollte man sich am besten anschauen? Ob da da so ein paar Tipps, wo man so rumgammeln sollte? Chats, Bücher, Online-Resourcen, Communities, Webforen.
Jede Menge, alles von dem. Mal auf den Berliner Android-Stammtisch. Jeden letzten.
Genau, wenn man in Berlin ist, gibt es einen Stammtisch, da kommen dann auch ab und zu Google-Mitarbeiter vorbei und verschenken Telefone.
Ich rach mal.
Einfach das Gerücht streuen. Das wird dann auf jeden Fall dazu, dass mehr Leute kommen.
Aber die gehen dann wieder ganz geknickt, wenn wir nur über irgendwelche Intents reden.
Aber der Stammtisch hat jetzt auch keinen Nachwuchssorgen, da tummeln sich schon ein paar Leute, oder?
Von dem Stammtisch gibt es auch eine deutsche Google Group, also D-Droid heißt die. Und dann gibt es ganz wichtig sind die englischsprachigen Google Groups, also Android-Developers ist der Einstieg, würde ich mal sagen. Und was ich noch, wo ich gute Erfahrungen gemacht habe, ist Android-Dev, der Irk-Channel. Wenn man mal schnell eine Antwort haben will, dann kann man die da gut kriegen.
Welchen ERC-Netzwerk?
Freenode, das sind glaube ich alle Freenode.
Da, wo die Developer sind, ja.
Es gibt noch Haschmark Android, da treffen sich eher die Modder und die anderen Leute, die was mit Android gerne machen oder auch die Leute, die über Android lästern wollen. Sonst gibt es noch Android Route, da geht es ums Routen von Android und Android Gear, also alles mit Haschmark davor. Und als Bücher...
Android Gear im Sinne von...
Und als Bücher finde ich ganz toll, die drei Bücher von Mark Murphy, die man als PDF lesen kann und auch sollte, weil sie nur da aktuell sind. Also die Bücher, wenn sie als Bücher gedruckt sind, sind schon hoffnungslos veraltet. Da kauft man sich, ich glaube für 30 Dollar, so eine Jahres-Subscription. Und wenn man da noch einen Fehler in einem seiner drei Bücher findet, dann kriegt man auch noch ein Jahr oben drauf.
Wie heißen die drei Bücher?
Die heißen Busy Coder Guide to Android, und dann noch Advanced Android und Android Tutorials. Also findet man auf commonsware.com. Da findet man die drei Bücher. Und die gibt es auch als EPUB. Ich habe sie mir ausgedruckt, als ich sie das erste Mal runtergeladen habe. Jetzt lese ich trotzdem immer nur die aktuellen PDFs. Also es lohnt sich nicht, die auszudrucken.
Keine Warnung an die Internet-Ausdrucker. Es lohnt sich nicht. Kost mal Geld.
Also bei uns als Erfahrung, könnte ich sagen, wir gucken halt viel in den Referenzen natürlich nach. Also auf Google Developers, also Android Developers. Ansonsten haben wir die meiste Erfahrung dadurch gesammelt, dass wir jemanden daneben sitzen haben, der schon mal was damit gemacht hat. Also als wir angefangen haben, war es natürlich ein bisschen mühselig. Aber ansonsten ist Extreme Programming und Pairing und so weiter Pair Programming ein extrem super tolles Mittel, um in so eine neue Plattform reinzukommen. Also wenn man irgendwie frisch damit anfangen will, am besten auf einen Android-Stammtisch kommen. Da hängen viele Leute rum mit vielen Ideen. Und da kann man einfach mal vielleicht jemanden fragen, ob man so ein Wochenende mal zusammen codet oder so und irgendwie eine Mini-App programmiert. Da lernt man extrem viel bei. Das ist so meine Erfahrung.
Ja, da muss ich mich jetzt auch für den Plug hier bedanken. Da kann ich nämlich gleich mal auf Grausradio Express 28 verweisen. Genau, mit Pavel, wo es um Extreme Programming geht. Einer meiner Lieblings-CHAEs. Im Übrigen, wer schon immer noch mal einen Tipp haben wollte, den fand ich außerordentlich gelungen und lehrreich. Haben wir denn auch irgendwas Wichtiges vergessen? Haben wir bestimmt, aber fällt es euch auch ein?
Na, den größten Mangel haben wir noch nicht erwähnt.
Den größten Mangel?
Den größten Mangel finde ich, dass man Applikationen nicht auf die SD-Karte speichern kann. Die Begründung dafür ist Kopierschutz, die ich nicht ganz einsehen kann.
Das ist eine etwas absurde Situation, weil die Telefone eigentlich gar nicht viel Speicher haben. Der meiste Speicher, den man überhaupt schaffen kann, ist diese SD-Karte. Zumindest beim Nexus One stand jetzt März 2010.
Genau, das war von Anfang an so. Beim G1 war es auch schon so.
Das heißt, man kann eigentlich große Programme überhaupt nicht... Was heißt das? Du sagst es doch vorhin, man kann über die SD-Karte-Programme ins System bringen, aber wenn sie nicht im internen Speicher sind, ist das nicht ein bisschen absurd, einen Kopierschutz zu machen, der verhindert, dass man die Programme...
Das mit dem Kopierschutz ist halt so. Im Market, das wollte ich vorhin eigentlich auch noch erwähnen, aber im Market gibst du der Developer an, es soll kopiergeschützt sein, und das ist dann ein Flag. Und das heißt dann einfach nur, dass es auf dem Telefon noch einen privaten Speicher gibt, wo die Applikation dann Sachen ablegen kann. Es gibt übrigens auch Probleme, wenn man von kopiergeschützt zu nicht kopiergeschützt wechselt, seine Applikation, also die nächste Version sozusagen nicht mehr kopiergeschützt ist, weil dann die Daten nicht rüberkopiert werden. Jedenfalls, wenn man root werden kann, und auch auf dem gekauften Telefon gibt es natürlich immer wieder Hacks, um irgendwie root zu werden, dann kann man natürlich auf diesen Speicher zugreifen, und dann kann man das Programm einfach runterkopieren, und dann kann man es einfach dann ist der Kopierschutz sozusagen kein wirklicher Kopierschutz, sondern es ist einfach nur ein Flag, was dem Telefon sagt, ich bin kopiergeschützt. Und sie wollen jetzt schon seit zwei Jahren, wie lange geht das jetzt schon, 2008, 2010 haben wir jetzt, also seit zwei Jahren wollen sie schon Apps zu SD irgendwie ermöglichen, das gibt es auch als Hack schon, aber nicht offiziell von Google, und sie sagen halt immer, wir machen es, werden wir das kryptographisch richtig gut hinbekommen, aber warum nicht die nicht kopiergeschützten Applikationen einfach so auf die SD-Karte installieren lassen? Ich meine, wenn die nicht kopiergeschützt sind, dann sind sie nicht kopiergeschützt.
Sind denn diese SD-Karten dann auch genauso schnell, wie man sie bräuchte?
Na also, die sind ja nicht so groß, die Apps in der Regel, obwohl die würden dann größer werden. Also was die Geschwindigkeit angeht, kann ich nicht sagen.
Also es kommt auf die SD-Karte, die man reintut. Also ich würde nicht unbedingt, also ich glaube, das ist halt auch eine Sache, Applikationen auf der SD-Karte ist eigentlich nicht das Hauptziel, sondern das Hauptziel ist irgendwie, genug Speicher für Applikationen zu haben.
Warum haben die Telefonen nicht, wenn man 32 GB hat?
Genau, das Einzige, das viel Speicher hat, ist Galaxy, oder? Oder es gibt vielleicht noch zwei, drei andere, aber das ist Droid oder das Milestone, haben auch nur 256 MB. Das Nexus One hat auch nur 300 MB, glaube ich. Internen Applikationsspeicher. Es gibt dann verschiedene Speicherarten. Es gibt internen Speicher für Applikationen und eben SD-Kartenspeicher.
Eine SD-Karte ist halt viel billiger, wahrscheinlich. Also einzustecken als irgendwie diesen eingelöteten Speicher, wie es das iPhone verwendet.
Vor allen Dingen bezahle ich die SD-Karte ja selber, weil die dabei ist, ist ja meist nur vier oder acht Gigabyte groß.
Das ist eine Frage von Salepoint. Irgendwie, wenn so ein Hersteller, könnte wahrscheinlich das auch machen, aber dann muss er da irgendwie 100 Euro mehr für verlangen und das macht einfach nicht...
Ich glaube, wenn ein Hersteller jetzt das Flash ab Werk da reinbaut, ist das natürlich billiger als eine SD-Karte, die erst mal... Plastik gegossen werden muss, über Vertriebskanäle geschickt werden muss und wieder Verkaufsmargen noch da drauf bekommt. Das sehe ich irgendwie nicht so richtig. So kann man den Preis des Telefons niedrig halten, indem man nicht Features einbaut wie zum Beispiel Speicher. Aber ehrlich gesagt, da fühle ich mich ja schon ein bisschen verarscht.
Also als das G1 rauskam und sich Leute beschwert haben, dass es nicht geht, hat Google in den Newsgroups, also Mitarbeiter von Google, das war jetzt keine offizielle Aussage, aber einer der Mitarbeiter, hat dann gesagt, na ja, es wird ja jetzt demnächst andere Telefone geben und die werden dann mehr internen Speicher haben. Und jetzt haben wir 2010 und die Telefone haben immer noch nur 300 Megabyte internen Speicher für Applikationen. Aber sie haben jetzt wohl tatsächlich angekündigt, dass sie jetzt das wirklich machen wollen demnächst.
Oh man, anstatt einfach mehr Speicher einzubauen.
Also mein Hauptnachteil, den ich im Moment finde, irgendwie bei diesem ganzen Android-Programmieren, ist einerseits, dass ich halt, ah nee, es gibt eigentlich zwei. Also eins ist irgendwie nur kurz am Rande, dass ich Java nicht so richtig mag und ich auf Java festgebunden bin.
Du könntest auch Scala nehmen.
Genau, ich kann Scala nehmen, vielleicht kann ich irgendwann mal Monodroid nehmen, also irgendwie.NET-Programmierung und so, da tut sich was. Was auch immer, das wollte ich nur mal ganz kurz anreißen. Wichtiger finde ich aber, dass im Moment diese Dalvik eben sehr langsam ist. Also habe ich ja schon mal kurz gesagt, irgendwie es fühlt sich an wie so ein Java Sun JDK 1.0 oder so. Also da ist keine Just-in-time-Compilation dabei. An der Stelle ist es langsam, garbage collection ist schlecht. Und gleichzeitig ist dieser ganze Fokus auch irgendwie so, das sind eigentlich Handy, also das Betriebssystem ist für Handys gebaut, die gerade erst rauskommen jetzt. Und das gibt es halt schon drei Jahre oder so. Weil also die ganze Grafikrendering passiert in Software. Also da wird richtig Software-Blitting gemacht. Das heißt, die CPU ist da total am Arbeiten. Deswegen funktioniert das auf dem Nexus auch so schön fluffy und locker flockig, weil das in einem Gigahertz CPU drin ist. Im Gegensatz zu so einem HTC Magic oder so, was halt nur 400 Megahertz hat. Das ist einfach irgendwie, Number-Crunching ist da extrem wichtig an der Stelle. Es sieht nicht so aus, als würden die irgendwann auf die Grafikkarte aufwechseln, sondern würden irgendwie auf Multicore warten oder was auch immer.
Das finde ich aber komisch, weil es gibt doch schon Hardware-Beschleunigung in Grafikkarten, auch EDL-tauglich.
Ja, aber diese ganze Grafik-Blitting und so weiter, wie diese Sachen, die gezeichnet werden, das kommt doch aus den Zeiten, bevor Google Android gekauft hat oder was auch immer. Und die machen das einfach. Das ist halt deren UI-Oberfläche und so weiter. Und das zu portieren nach Grafik-Shader und so weiter ist extrem aufwendig. Ich habe mit den Leuten von Z-Labs gesprochen, die haben ja so eine Entwickler-Plattform, wo sie so etwas wie ein iPod Touch von Creative, so eine Ausgründung, mit Z-Ii heißen die. Und ein Z-Egg ist so eine Entwickler-Test-Plattform wie ein iPod Touch, wo ein Android auch drauf läuft. Also die haben irgendwie ihre eigene Plattform, Plasma heißt die. Und man kann aber auch einen Android drauf installieren. Und die werben damit, dass sie zwar eine kleinere CPU haben und weniger Megahertz und so, aber dafür so SPUs. So ähnlich wie bei der Playstation, aber für mobil. Single Processing Units, kleine Sachen, die Assembler-Code ausführen können, die dann mit eigenem Speicher auch arbeiten können und so weiter. Und die werben damit, dass sie jetzt Android total schnell gemacht haben. Dieses ganze Grafik-Blitting, was ja irgendwie in Software da passiert, auf der CPU normalerweise, das haben sie halt in ihrem Android-Version ausgegliedert. Also weil die einen Sourcecode ja haben, ausgegliedert auf diese SPUs. Wir haben so ein Ding bei Artcom Rumliegen. Das Grafik-Blitting ist traumhaft schön schnell, aber da ist nur eine 200 oder 300 Megahertz CPU drin. Das heißt, alles andere ist super langsam und deswegen ist es auch wieder nix. Also es fühlt sich genauso schnell an wie alles andere auch. Aber an der Stelle wird sich was tun. Also ob jetzt irgendwie Graf... Also klar, eigentlich will man eine 3D-Beschleunigung auf so einem Handy. Also das spart Strom, das spart alles. Vor allen Dingen sind da drei Drehchips sehr drin. Man kann ja OpenGL machen. Aber sie benutzen es halt nicht. Also selbst diese Living Backgrounds, das ist alles. Jeder Pixel per Software. Deswegen ist auch ein Android-Emulator umso langsamer, desto größer du den Screen machst. Das kann man schön beobachten. Weil der emuliert halt irgendwie einen Arm-CPU, der versucht, diese Software-Blitting zu machen, auf einer Intel, also über Quemo halt. Und das wird einfach richtig langsam.
Na, aber der dann aussieht, wenn da noch Room for Improvement wäre.
Auf jeden Fall. Vielleicht ist es auch tatsächlich eine Architektur-Entscheidung. Und wir werden jetzt in dem nächsten Jahr oder in den nächsten paar Jahren richtig was auf der Performance-Front sehen. Und dieses System ist extrem mächtig, einfach weil es so offen und so frei ist. Wir haben bei Artcom auch uns selber X86-Android-Versionen compilert, wo wir dann halt keinen Mauszeiger für Touch screens haben wollen und so weiter. Also man kann da extrem viel speziellen Code machen und Sonderbehandlungen, wenn man will. Applikationen sind sehr frei und das wird auch noch viel freier werden. Also noch viel offener, noch viel mehr motivierender für Entwickler, sich neue Sachen auszudenken, die es vorher noch nie gab.
Alles wird freier.
Wir müssen nur unsere Daten abgeben.
Wir müssen nur die Daten abgeben und immer schön auf die Werbebanner klicken. Das ist ganz wichtig. Ja, mir fällt jetzt auch nichts mehr ein. Ich meine, wir können jetzt noch stundenlang darüber sein, was vielleicht irgendwann mal sein könnte. Aber ich denke, da mache ich dann lieber nochmal den nächsten CRE, wenn es dann irgendwann mal auch wirklich neue Erkenntnisse gibt. Insofern danke ich mich, Roger, Dirk, für die Ausführung zu Android. Das war es. Chaos Radio Express 152. Wieder mal eine kleine Technik-Ausgabe, wie es ja hier auch sehr beliebt ist. Und bald geht es hier wieder weiter mit auch den anderen Schwerpunkten Kultur und Gesellschaft. Ich sage tschüss und bis bald bei Chaos Radio Express.
Auf Wiedersehen!